- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
ouverte.
Madame la Première ministre,
mesdames et messieurs les membres
du gouvernement, mesdames et
messieurs les députés, chers
collègues, j'ai l'honneur
d'accueillir, nous avons l'honneur
d'accueillir aujourd'hui dans
notre hémicycle monsieur Rouslan
Stefantchouk, le président de la
Rada ukrainienne.
Il y a quelques mois, une
délégation de l'Assemblée
nationale s'est rendue à Kiev.
J'étais à sa tête.
Nous sommes allés dire l'appui
indéfectible des députés français
à l'Ukraine et à son peuple.
Le président Stefantchouk nous a
accueillis chaleureusement.
Avec lui, nous sommes allés au
contact des Ukrainiens.
Nous avons vu leur extraordinaire
résistance, leur détermination à
se battre contre l'agresseur russe
et leurs premiers efforts pour
reconstruire le pays.
A cette occasion, monsieur le
président de la Rada, vous nous
avez demandé d'être votre
porte-voix auprès de l'opinion
publique française et
internationale.
C'est ce que nous avons fait.
Le 30 novembre dernier, en effet,
l'Assemblée nationale, à l'issue
d'un débat nourri, a voté une
résolution affirmant le soutien de
l'Assemblée nationale à l'Ukraine
et condamnant la guerre menée par
la Fédération de Russie.
Depuis, plusieurs députés se sont
rendus à Kiev pour marquer leur
soutien.
Aujourd'hui, pour la venue de
monsieur Stefantchouk, l'Assemblée
nationale arbore les couleurs
ukrainiennes avec l'exposition des
oeuvres d'un artiste que nous
venons d'inaugurer ensemble, puis
plusieurs réunions associant nos
commissions permanentes et le
groupe d'amitié France-Ukraine
nouvellement constitué.
L'agression russe se poursuit,
effroyable, avec son lot
d'exactions, de crimes de guerre,
de bombardements aveugles et de
destruction.
Chaque jour apporte des nouvelles
accablantes, mais aussi chaque
jour, les démocraties s'unissent
pour apporter tout le soutien
nécessaire à l'Ukraine.
L'Ukraine doit gagner cette
guerre.
Elle doit retrouver son intégrité
territoriale et la paix.
Applaudissements
Pour la soutenir dans son combat,
la représentation nationale est
pleinement mobilisée aux côtés du
gouvernement français car le
combat de l'Ukraine, c'est plus
largement celui de nos valeurs
démocratiques, celui de
l'humanisme, de la liberté.
Nos deux assemblées viennent de
signer un protocole d'accord
particulièrement utile pour
préparer l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'Union Européenne.
En effet, l'Ukraine fait partie de
la famille européenne et son
destin se trouve dans l'Union
Européenne.
Monsieur Stefantchouk, président,
quand vous reviendrez à Kiev, vous
pourrez témoigner de l'entière
mobilisation de la représentation
nationale française en faveur du
peuple ukrainien et de sa
souveraineté.
...
C'est avec beaucoup d'émotion,
beaucoup de plaisir et beaucoup
d'amitié que je vous cède à
présent la parole et que je vous
invite à monter à la tribune de
l'Assemblée.
- Rouslan Stefantchouk: Chère
madame la présidente, chère madame
la Première ministre, mesdames et
messieurs les députés, chers amis,
tout d'abord, maintenant, à cette
haute tribune, je voudrais vous
remercier, chère madame la
présidente, pour cette possibilité
de prendre la parole devant les
députés de l'Assemblée nationale
française, au coeur même de la vie
politique de votre pays.
Il est très important pour nous
que nos amis et partenaires
puissent entendre les Ukrainiens
et puissent voir, comme vous
l'avez fait, madame, pendant votre
visite en Ukraine.
Chère Yaël, je me souviens
jusqu'au moindre détail de votre
visite à Kiev.
Ensuite, nous nous sommes rendus
ensemble en train dans une ville
voisine.
C'était un acte de courage.
Je n'oublierai jamais, madame la
présidente, comment vous avez tenu
les mains d'une femme âgée qui a
survécu après une frappe de
missiles sur sa maison.
Vous avez pu voir de vos propres
yeux l'ampleur des destructions
dans notre pays.
Vous avez ressenti la douleur et
le malheur de chaque Ukrainien.
Votre visite est devenue un
témoignage éclatant de solidarité
de la République française avec
l'Ukraine, une manifestation de
soutien de notre indépendance et
de notre intégrité territoriale.
Ce sont des principes qui nous
réunissent.
Ce qui nous réunit aussi, ce sont
les ponts que la France
fraternelle a transmis à
l'Ukraine, qui ont renforcé les
ponts d'amitié et d'aide
humanitaire entre nos deux pays et
qui ont été renforcés par les
ponts de soutien militaire et
technique accordés à l'Ukraine et
à travers lesquels arrivent en
Ukraine les militaires et les
équipements.
Nous construirons de nouveaux
ponts qui vont réunir encore
davantage nos deux pays.
Cela fait presque un an que
l'agression à grande échelle de la
Russie contre l'Ukraine a
commencé.
Comme personne d'autre, nous
comprenons parfaitement que son
unique intention était
l'aspiration criminelle de la
Russie de s'emparer du territoire,
de priver l'Ukraine de
souveraineté, d'empêcher notre
avenir européen.
La Russie utilise contre nous
l'ensemble des armes dont elle
dispose.
Elle fait chanter le monde en
utilisant ses armes de destruction
massive.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai eu une
possibilité exceptionnelle de
tenir dans mes mains les trésors
de votre bibliothèque, comme un
grand atlas sur les cartes où est
représentée la ville de Kherson,
qui a été récemment libérée par
l'armée ukrainienne.
De plus, j'ai eu l'occasion de
voir un livre exceptionnel édité
en 1660 par un grand ingénieur,
cartographe et voyageur français,
avec une description de l'Ukraine.
Il y a dans ce texte des paroles
nobles sur des cosaques.
On lit que c'est un peuple subtil
qui n'aspire pas à devenir riche,
mais qui aide à leur grande
liberté sans laquelle ils ne
pourraient vivre.
L'Ukraine résiste.
L'Ukraine se bat car aujourd'hui
aussi, elle n'imagine pas sa vie
sans la liberté.
L'agresseur répond par des
attaques contre nos villes et nos
villages, contre des sites
d'infrastructures qui privent les
gens de chauffage, d'électricité
et d'eau.
Depuis ce matin, depuis notre
réunion, les Ukrainiens sont
descendus à trois reprises dans
les abris pour sauver leur vie des
missiles russes.
L'agresseur aspire à priver les
Ukrainiens de conditions dignes
d'existence.
La propagande cynique russe
continue à produire des mensonges
et des fake news pour ses propres
concitoyens et tous ceux qui y
croient encore dans le monde.
De fait, ils participent à ce
crime qui doit être puni.
Tous les responsables doivent être
traduits devant la justice.
Ce sont les terroristes qui font
cela, et c'est ainsi qu'agit un
régime et un Etat terroriste.
C'est une politique irresponsable
qui porte une menace pour la
liberté et la démocratie.
La communauté internationale doit
apporter une appréciation
adéquate.
Le 23 novembre dernier, le
Parlement européen a reconnu la
Russie comme un Etat promoteur de
terrorisme qui utilise des
méthodes terroristes.
Une décision identique avait été
prise par les assemblées
parlementaires de l'OTAN et du
Conseil de l'Europe.
Par conséquent, à cette tribune,
je vous appelle, chers collègues,
à reconnaître la Russie comme un
Etat terroriste dans les murs de
votre temple de droit et de
liberté.
Applaudissements
Dans ces murs ont été adoptées des
décisions importantes, et le 30
novembre de l'année dernière, la
résolution de soutenir l'Ukraine
adoptée dans ces murs à condamner
l'agression russe.
Ce qui est important, c'est que
cette résolution soutient l'idée
de la création d'un tribunal
spécial.
C'est ce tribunal qui doit établir
chaque nom de chaque criminel,
depuis les idéologues de cette
agression insensée jusqu'à ceux
qui ont donné des ordres directs,
ceux qui ont tué, ceux qui ont
violé, ceux qui ont mutilé.
Personne ne doit échapper à sa
responsabilité car c'est cela, la
justice.
Je remercie le peuple français,
son président et son gouvernement,
vous tous, pour toute aide qui a
été apportée à l'Ukraine depuis le
début de cette agression à grande
échelle contre l'Ukraine, et avant
tout pour l'aide militaire.
Nous avons décidé de renforcer
l'Ukraine avec des défenses
antiaériennes.
Les chars et les blindés sont
devenus des impulsions pour les
autres pays de prendre la même
décision.
La France a toujours été et sera
un leader.
Grâce à vous, le lexique français
s'enrichit de nouveaux mots.
Aujourd'hui, nous savons ce que
signifient Crotale, Caesar,
AMX-10, et nous sommes prêts à
continuer à enrichir notre
vocabulaire avec d'autres mots.
Nous voulons voir, parmi les
Abrams, les Leopard, les
Challengers, les chars Leclerc
français qui nous renforceront au
sol, mais aussi les Mirage et les
Rafale qui, avec d'autres avions,
protégeront le ciel ukrainien.
Donnez-nous les avions,
donnez-nous les ailes de notre
victoire.
...
Ces ailes nous protégeront, mais
aussi l'ensemble de l'Europe.
Chers membres de l'Assemblée
nationale, la plus grande valeur
que nous partageons, c'est l'être
humain.
Je remercie le peuple français,
toutes les familles françaises qui
ont accueilli les Ukrainiens.
Je les remercie au nom de chacun
de mes 100.000 concitoyens qui ont
trouvé refuge en France.
...
Vous avez donné aux enfants
ukrainiens la possibilité de
poursuivre leurs études, leur
scolarité.
Vous avez assuré aux Ukrainiens
une protection sociale.
Vous avez créé les possibilités
pour qu'ils trouvent un travail.
Nous n'oublierons jamais votre
attitude à l'égard de nos
concitoyens.
Vous les avez accueillis comme les
membres de votre propre famille,
de la famille française et
européenne.
L'Ukraine revient à ses sources
européennes malgré la résistance
féroce de Moscou.
Nous remercions de tout coeur la
France d'avoir accordé à l'Ukraine
le statut de candidat à l'Union
Européenne.
Le peuple ukrainien paye
aujourd'hui un prix
extraordinairement fort.
Notre peuple connaîtra une
floraison au sein de la grande
famille européenne.
Nous travaillons sur les lois et
l'introduction des réformes
nécessaires.
Nous savons ce que nous devons
faire et comment le faire.
Nous avançons le plus vite
possible, même dans les conditions
de la guerre.
Je voudrais souligner que le
président de l'Ukraine, le
Parlement et le gouvernement font
preuve d'une tolérance zéro à
l'égard de la corruption, et ils
se battent pour éradiquer ce
phénomène.
Durant les 10 derniers jours, il y
a eu des fonctionnaires de haut
niveau peu scrupuleux qui seront
condamnés, qui répondront de leurs
actes, car c'est cela, la
démocratie.
L'Ukraine terminera le plus vite
possible et accomplira toutes les
mesures établies par la Commission
européenne.
J'espère que cela nous permettra,
dès cette année, d'ouvrir les
pourparlers pour l'entrée à
l'Union Européenne.
Nous espérons également que la
France donnera le soutien
politique aux membres ukrainiens
de son adhésion accélérée dans le
contexte du sommet de l'Alliance
qui aura lieu les 11 et 12 juillet
2023.
Nous avons prouvé par notre lutte
que nous pouvons et que nous
devons devenir membres de la
famille européenne, mais aussi de
l'Alliance atlantique.
Chère Assemblée nationale, nous
recourons souvent à l'histoire.
Nous y cherchons les explications
de ce qui se passe et de ce qui
nous arrive aujourd'hui.
Je voudrais évoquer ici, dans ce
noble cercle, un phénomène et un
événement historique, la famine.
Suite aux actions génocidaires du
régime de Staline, en raison de
cette famine artificielle
organisée en 1932 et 1933, des
millions d'Ukrainiens ont péri.
C'est aujourd'hui le signal venant
de France, en reconnaissant la
famine en tant que génocide, qui
sera un signal fort.
Comme par le passé, le régime de
Poutine n'aspire qu'à une chose:
détruire la nation ukrainienne.
...
Dès lors, chers collègues, je vous
demande de contribuer à la
reconnaissance législative de la
famine de 1932-1933 en tant que
génocide du peuple ukrainien.
Chers amis, cette guerre se
terminera par notre victoire
commune, j'en suis persuadé.
Après cette victoire viendra la
période de reconstruction et de
restauration.
Nous espérons aussi que la France,
votre gouvernement, vos milieux
d'affaires, pourront se joindre de
manière active à cette
reconstruction de l'Ukraine de
l'après-guerre, cette
reconstruction doit constituer un
succès du monde civilisé.
Chers amis, aujourd'hui, je
m'adresse à vous au nom de tous
les Ukrainiens qui se battent
aujourd'hui et qui donnent leur
vie pour leur liberté et leur
dignité.
Je parle au nom des citoyens
ukrainiens qui, ce jour même,
aident l'armée, continuent à
croire en leur liberté.
Nous voulons vivre dans une
société pacifique et civilisée que
personne ne menace.
C'est pour ça que nous proposons
la formule de la paix.
Au sommet du G20, le président
Zelensky a proposé aux leaders
mondiaux un plan de fin de guerre.
Notre formule de la paix se
constitue en 10 points.
Nous voyons que la France est un
leader puissant qui aidera à
réaliser ce plan.
C'est précisément grâce à l'aide
de la France et de nos autres
partenaires et alliés que nous
voulons fixer les points-clés de
la structure post-guerre dans
l'espace atlantique comprenant les
garanties pour l'Ukraine.
Nous comptons beaucoup sur le
soutien de cette formule de la
paix proposée par le président
ukrainien de la part de la France.
En Ukraine, tout le monde a
parfaitement entendu les paroles
du président Macron.
Nous serons ensemble pour
construire un monde juste et
solide.
Comptez sur la France, comptez sur
l'Europe.
Nous avons entendu ces paroles
sous les tirs.
Nous les avons entendues sur les
champs de bataille.
Ces paroles ont retenti plus fort
que les explosions des obus et des
sirènes.
En guise de conclusion,
permettez-moi de partager avec
vous un rêve.
Je me souviens comment, en 2012,
lors de l'Euro 2012, il y a eu un
match entre les équipes nationales
de France et d'Ukraine.
Cela avait eu lieu à Donetsk.
Ce match avait été interrompu par
un orage.
Moins de deux ans plus tard,
l'agression russe a interrompu
notre vie pacifique.
La guerre est entrée dans notre
maison, apportant la mort et la
destruction.
Je voudrais tant que nous
puissions gagner ensemble dans ce
match contre la mort et que nos
équipes nationales puissent de
nouveau jouer dans ce stade de
Donetsk.
Et ce sera le match de notre
victoire commune.
Ce sera le match de la paix et de
la mémoire.
Ce sera le match de la nouvelle
vie.
Je vous remercie de votre
attention.
Gloire à l'Ukraine et vive la
France.
Applaudissements nourris
...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le président.
Merci, au nom de la représentation
nationale.
Je vais vous proposer de suspendre
deux minutes, le temps que le
président Stefantchouk puisse
s'installer dans la tribune que
nous avons pavoisée aux couleurs
de l'Ukraine.
Nous aurons ensuite les
interventions de chaque groupe
politique, ainsi que nous en avons
décidé en conférence des
présidents.
Juste deux minutes de suspension.
Je vous propose de rester à vos
places.
Nous reprenons dès qu'il est
installé en tribune.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Cette séance
donnera lieu à une réponse groupée
de madame la Première ministre.
La première question sera celle de
monsieur André Chassaigne.
- André Chassaigne: Madame la
présidente, madame la Première
ministre, des enfants, des femmes
frappées par les bombes, tous
jetés sur les routes, par
millions, des centaines de
milliers de civils et de soldats
tués.
Voilà le terrible bilan de la
folie meurtrière déclenchée voici
près d'un an par le sinistre
Poutine, qui a fait le choix
irresponsable d'envahir l'Ukraine,
le choix du sang et des larmes,
violant les règles du droit
international, mettant en péril la
sécurité en Europe, relançant une
désastreuse course aux armements.
Ce constat implacable nous
rappelle une évidence: notre seul
horizon doit être celui de la
paix, oui, la paix, sans que cette
exigence ne puisse être perçue
comme un signe de capitulation.
Il y a bien un agresseur, il est
clairement désigné, et un pays en
état de légitime défense que nous
soutenons sans ambiguïté en lui
apportant les moyens de se
défendre pleinement.
C'est dans ce cadre que doit
continuer de s'inscrire notre
engagement militaire, avec la
volonté de ne pas devenir
co-belligérant et de ne pas
participer à une escalade
guerrière par la livraison d'armes
lourdes offensives qui seraient
bien plus qu'un simple
enrichissement du vocabulaire.
Nous avons aussi un devoir tout
aussi important, celui de porter
assistance à une population
courageuse plongée dans le tumulte
et le chaos.
C'est ce que nous faisons dans nos
communes depuis le début du
conflit, grâce à l'action des élus
et des bénévoles, grâce à la
générosité des familles d'accueil
de réfugiés.
Je veux saluer ici ce mouvement
fraternel, cette main tendue à nos
amis ukrainiens représentés
aujourd'hui par le président de
l'Assemblée nationale.
Ce soutien passe aussi par la
recherche d'une solution
diplomatique la plus rapide
possible, comme le demandent les
mouvements pacifistes de l'Ukraine
et de la Russie, ouvrir les
chemins de la paix, à l'inverse
d'une escalade guerrière dans
laquelle aucune limite ne serait
plus osée dans l'utilisation des
armes les plus destructrices.
N'oublions jamais, chers
collègues, les 80 millions de
morts des deux guerres mondiales
du siècle passé.
Il nous semble urgent de remettre
l'ONU au centre des discussions.
Membre permanent du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU, la France a un
rôle important à jouer dans ce
cadre-là.
Madame la Première ministre, la
France est-elle prête à engager
des moyens diplomatiques plus
importants auprès de l'ONU pour
parvenir à un cadre de sécurité
durable par toutes les parties
impliquées?
Etes-vous prête aussi à répondre
favorablement à la demande que
j'ai formulée avec mon collègue
Fabien Roussel pour que soit
organisé ici même un débat sur la
position de la France concernant
la livraison d'armes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Panot.
- Mathilde Panot: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
monsieur le président de la Rada,
notre groupe parlementaire
souhaite tout d'abord adresser
tout son soutien à ses homologues
députés ukrainiens ainsi qu'au
peuple ukrainien meurtri par la
guerre.
Nous formons le voeu qu'une
solution diplomatique soit trouvée
au plus vite afin de garantir le
retour à la paix.
Madame la Première ministre, oui,
il relève du devoir de la France
de soutenir l'Ukraine, d'aider les
Ukrainiens, y compris
militairement.
Toutefois, ces derniers jours,
l'Allemagne, les Etats-Unis et
d'autres pays ont annoncé la
livraison d'armes lourdes à
l'Ukraine.
Notre préoccupation est double:
que les Ukrainiens puissent se
défendre face à l'agression des
Russes, et que les risques de
montée en puissance dans les
conflits soient évités.
Indépendamment du fait de savoir
si nous disposons de stock
suffisant ou si nos équipements
sont adaptés pour nous dans cette
voie, nous partageons tous ici la
volonté de ne pas alimenter une
logique d'escalade et de
précipiter notre pays au seuil
d'une guerre totale.
Le président de la République
lui-même est conscient de ce
danger.
Il ne disait pas autre chose en
octobre 2022 que ceci: "Nous
soutenons l'Ukraine dans sa
résistance, sans participer à la
guerre, parce que nous ne voulons
pas de guerre mondiale."
Nous partageons cette position.
C'est pourquoi nous demandons à ce
qu'un débat soit organisé à
l'Assemblée nationale sur le rôle
que la France doit tenir.
Pour cela, les parlementaires
doivent pouvoir disposer des
informations stratégiques afin
d'éclairer leur réflexion.
La gravité de ces enjeux mérite un
débat démocratique, et je sais que
plusieurs groupes sur des bancs
différents y sont favorables.
Par ailleurs, l'invasion russe en
Ukraine pose la question à long
terme de la reconstruction du
pays.
Notre assemblée a reçu récemment
en commission des Affaires
étrangères, sur proposition de
notre groupe, une délégation des
défenseurs de l'environnement
ukrainiens, parmi lesquels une
députée de la Rada.
Une de leurs revendications est la
prise en compte de l'écologie dans
le processus de reconstruction.
Les saccages ne doivent pas
laisser place au saccage de
multinationales.
J'espère qu'à ce titre, vous vous
désolidarisez des propos du
président délégué du MEDEF tenus à
Bercy au sujet de la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine.
La période appelle à la décence,
et les horreurs de la guerre ne
sauraient représenter une
opportunité économique.
Nous voulons là aussi un débat
dans notre assemblée sur les
modalités françaises et
européennes à la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine afin que notre Parlement
soit associé à ce processus.
Pour finir, permettez-moi
d'adresser au nom de mon groupe un
soutien politique et humaniste au
peuple ukrainien.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est au président Marleix
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Olivier Marleix: Madame la
Première ministre, monsieur le
président de la Rada, à travers
vous, c'est l'engagement, le
courage et la résistance du peuple
ukrainien que nous voulons honorer
cet après-midi.
Jour après jour, il force
l'admiration du monde.
Il n'y a aucun doute pour nous,
oui, la Russie a violé la
souveraineté ukrainienne et porte
seule la responsabilité du retour
de la guerre en Europe, avec son
cortège insensé de crimes contre
l'humanité, de Boutcha à Kharkiv.
La France doit aider l'Ukraine et
notre pays n'a pas cessé d'étendre
son soutien militaire, humanitaire
et financier.
Mais, madame la Première ministre,
le conflit figé depuis l'automne
connaît des mouvements inquiétants
depuis plusieurs semaines, avec la
perspective d'une offensive russe
de grande ampleur, qui pourrait
compter jusqu'à un demi-million de
nouveaux conscrits.
Le président Poutine est habité
par des idées de destruction et de
reddition de l'Ukraine, engagé
dans une guerre qui n'a aucun sens
politico-économique, sauf à
vouloir reconstituer l'URSS.
Les espoirs de retrouver une porte
de sortie négociée à court terme
s'amenuisent devant
l'intransigeance russe.
Bien sûr, aucune négociation n'est
possible tant que l'Ukraine est
sous les bombes.
Aujourd'hui, la France, grande
puissance, puissance européenne,
membre du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU, a vocation à imaginer la
fin de la guerre.
Aujourd'hui, pourtant, elle ne
fait pas entendre sa voix
singulière.
Notre pays donne le sentiment
d'être à la remorque de ses
partenaires européens et de son
allié américain, parfois en
décalage avec eux, en tout cas
sans initiatives propres.
Ce n'est pas à la hauteur de notre
histoire.
Sans doute la position française
souffre-t-elle de l'isolement du
président de la République jusque
dans son propre pays, une des
seules démocraties dans laquelle
le chef de l'Etat ne partage pas
ses opinions stratégiques avec le
Parlement.
Vous devez vous appuyer sur le
Parlement pour construire la
position française, et notamment
partager avec nous un état des
lieux réaliste de nos capacités de
soutien militaire.
Vous devez nous dire quels sont
les scénarios de désescalade et de
paix pour l'Ukraine qui guident
votre gouvernement.
Madame la Première ministre, la
solidarité de la France envers le
peuple ukrainien sera d'autant
plus solide qu'elle sera éclairée
et partagée.
Etes-vous prête à organiser ce
débat au Parlement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Bergé pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
monsieur le président, la Rada
d'Ukraine est, à l'instar de
toutes les assemblées
démocratiques, soeur de notre
Assemblée nationale.
Votre présence aujourd'hui est
d'autant plus symbolique que cela
fait bientôt un an que la Russie a
déclenché ce qu'elle refuse encore
et toujours à admettre et à
appeler une invasion.
Malgré des dizaines de milliers de
morts, malgré les bombes lancées
sur de nombreuses villes, malgré
les milliers de crimes de guerre,
tortures, viols, attaques
délibérées et ciblées d'écoles et
d'hôpitaux, exécutions sommaires
et malgré les souffrances
infligées à tout un peuple, un
peuple dont Vladimir Poutine est
depuis un an le persécuteur et le
bourreau systématique, malgré le
déséquilibre des forces, malgré
l'agression préméditée et massive
de l'armée russe, l'Ukraine a
tenu.
Elle a tenu d'abord grâce au
courage de ses citoyens et de ses
dirigeants.
Elle a tenu aussi parce que nous,
Français, Européens, nous avons
répondu présent en sanctionnant
durement la Russie quand certains
nous demandaient de cesser toute
sanction et malgré le prix à
payer.
Nous avons montré que nos valeurs
ne sont pas à vendre.
En accueillant des millions
d'Ukrainiens, nous avons redit que
la solidarité n'était pas un vain
mot.
Nous avons prouvé que les
intimidations ne nous empêcheront
jamais de venir en aide à un Etat
souverain et à un peuple libre.
Merci, monsieur le président, pour
les mots que vous avez eus pour
notre pays et nos concitoyens, car
oui, dans toutes ses actions, la
France a fait honneur à ses
principes.
Elle a organisé en décembre un
sommet qui a permis de récolter
des millions d'euros d'aide
d'urgence de reconstruction pour
l'Ukraine.
La France a aussi annoncé la
première l'envoi de chars aux
armées ukrainiennes.
A ceux qui posent la question:
jusqu'à quand soutiendrez-vous
l'Ukraine, nous ne donnons qu'une
seule réponse: jusqu'à la victoire
de l'Ukraine.
Nous serons à vos côtés tant que
l'Ukraine n'aura pas recouvré sa
pleine souveraineté et les
Ukrainiens, leur liberté.
Nous serons à vos côtés pour
célébrer demain votre appartenance
à l'Union Européenne.
Madame la Première ministre, alors
qu'une nouvelle attaque massive de
la Russie est à craindre pour le
printemps, il nous incombe encore
et toujours de continuer à
soutenir les Ukrainiens.
Quel nouveau soutien militaire la
France va-t-elle fournir en
coordination avec ses alliés pour
soutenir encore et toujours la
résistance du peuple ukrainien?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Le Pen.
- Marine Le Pen: Madame la
Première ministre, monsieur le
président, chers collègues, nous
sommes profondément touchés par le
drame que subit le peuple
ukrainien.
C'est pourquoi nous avons toujours
condamné l'invasion du territoire
souverain de l'Ukraine et nous
avons toujours appelé au
rétablissement des principes du
droit international piétinés
depuis bien trop d'années par ceux
qui devraient les défendre.
Cette guerre européenne fratricide
a vu naître une remarquable
mobilisation, cherchant à atténuer
la souffrance de ceux qui
subissent cette guerre.
Cette mobilisation est le
témoignage de notre identité car
elle ne s'est pas seulement faite
par l'action des nations, mais
aussi par des initiatives locales,
rassemblant dans un même élan les
peuples et leur corps politique.
L'accueil des réfugiés, le soutien
matériel nécessaire à un peuple
souffrant du froid et de la faim
est admirable.
Si nous comprenons la politique de
livraison d'armes défensives qui
rejoint cette volonté de défendre
la souveraineté et l'intégrité
territoriale des nations, il est
légitime de s'interroger sur une
poursuite de l'escalade dont
l'issue nous est inconnue.
La poursuite de cette guerre n'est
pas seulement un drame humain,
mais risque de renverser
définitivement l'équilibre du
monde.
La victoire militaire de la Russie
lancerait un signal dramatique à
ceux qui, demain, pensent pouvoir
régler leurs conflits territoriaux
par la force.
La livraison au compte-gouttes
d'armements offensifs signerait
probablement une guerre de 100
ans.
Un engagement total de l'OTAN,
seule hypothèse permettant
véritablement d'envisager une
victoire de l'Ukraine, conduirait
à une troisième guerre mondiale.
Sans résolution diplomatique du
conflit, ceux qui siègent au
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
auront échoué à défendre la paix.
Ils seront retournés à
l'application de la loi du plus
fort, annihilant ainsi la
souveraineté des peuples et
l'espoir de justice
internationale.
C'est pourquoi nous soutenons les
actions diplomatiques du
gouvernement en faveur de la paix.
L'instabilité géopolitique
mondiale, conséquence des choix de
la Russie, nous oblige à une
grande prudence.
Les nouvelles alliances de la
Russie sont devenues des
partenaires privilégiés de l'Inde
et de la Chine.
Alors que la paix a disparu des
consciences, il est nécessaire de
commencer dès aujourd'hui son
édification.
C'est pourquoi je vous demande
solennellement si le président
peut faire entendre au monde qu'un
espoir demeure, en organisant avec
l'ensemble des parties une grande
conférence pour la paix.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est au président
Marcangeli pour le groupe
Horizons.
- Laurent Marcangeli: Merci.
Merci, monsieur le président, pour
votre intervention.
Votre présence ici nous engage et
je veux, au nom du groupe Horizons
et apparentés, vous réaffirmer
tout notre soutien, comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le faire chez vous,
à Kiev, en décembre dernier.
Madame la Première ministre,
presque un an après le début de la
guerre en Ukraine, 90 ans après la
plus grande famine qu'a connue le
pays, voici que ressurgit le
spectre de la mort.
Une nouvelle fois, la Russie
menace la sécurité alimentaire des
peuples.
C'est nécessairement l'affaire de
tous.
Rappelons qu'avant l'invasion
russe, l'Ukraine était le
quatrième exportateur mondial de
maïs et de blé.
Avec la guerre, la Russie a
d'abord imposé un blocus en mer
Noire, levé au prix d'âpres
négociations sur les exportations
maritimes.
Depuis, les dommages continuent
sur les infrastructures de
stockage et les machines
agricoles.
Les agriculteurs sont donc en
première ligne dans ce conflit.
Il a fallu aider l'Ukraine à
écouler sa production malgré les
blocus.
La France et l'Union Européenne
l'ont fait en créant un corridor
de solidarité dont la logistique a
permis de générer 15 milliards
d'euros de revenus en Ukraine.
Mais les capacités de ce
dispositif sont limitées car son
coût logistique est présent.
Pour qu'il continue de porter ses
fruits, des investissements
supplémentaires doivent être
consentis.
L'Union Européenne finance
également un programme de soutien
pour les agriculteurs ukrainiens.
Face à l'invasion russe, l'aide
militaire est une nécessité à
court terme, mais nous devons
aussi nous engager pour que ce
conflit n'aggrave pas une famine
mondiale déjà fortement accrue par
les sécheresses sur le continent
africain.
Madame la Première ministre, si un
nouveau blocus devait s'engager en
mer Noire, comment pouvons-nous
améliorer et pérenniser les
corridors de solidarité?
Pouvons-nous envisager d'autres
programmes de soutien aux
agriculteurs ukrainiens?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur le
président Vallaud pour le groupe
socialiste.
- Boris Vallaud: Merci.
Monsieur le président de la Rada,
mes chers collègues, après avoir
entendu le président Zelensky
s'exprimer depuis Kiev dans ce
même hémicycle et après avoir
rencontré le Premier ministre dans
l'enceinte du palais Bourbon, je
veux remercier aujourd'hui le
président de la Rada de sa
présence.
Je veux vous renouveler ici,
madame la Première ministre, le
soutien indéfectible des députés
socialistes et apparentés aux
actions et à l'aide en faveur de
l'Ukraine de la France et de
l'Union Européenne menés depuis ce
funeste 24 février.
Je veux soutenir les sanctions
décidées à l'encontre de la Russie
et de Vladimir Poutine.
Nous avons eu l'occasion de dire
ce soutien à travers le dépôt ou
le vote de résolutions.
Nous avons pu également le faire
de façon plus directe à travers la
voix de Valérie Rabault
lorsqu'elle vous a accompagnée,
madame la présidente, lors d'un
déplacement d'une délégation
française en Ukraine.
Nous portons aujourd'hui l'espoir,
avec beaucoup d'entre vous, et la
conviction que la victoire contre
l'obscurantisme du régime de
Poutine est non seulement
possible, mais demeure nécessaire.
Une victoire qui ne pourra être
complète que lorsque l'Ukraine
aura recouvré sa pleine et entière
souveraineté.
Ce sont des frontières entièrement
reconnues, celles de 1991.
Cette victoire nécessitera aussi
la mise en place d'un tribunal
spécial visant à établir et à
juger les responsabilités des
crimes commis dans cette guerre,
une victoire qui exigera la
libération de tous les Ukrainiens
déportés en Russie ainsi que
l'indemnisation des crimes
accomplis sur son sol.
Cependant, je voudrais aujourd'hui
vous interroger sur une autre aide
que nous devons à l'Ukraine.
Si gagner la guerre est un défi
redoutable, gagner la paix civile
durable après un tel conflit n'en
est pas moins un défi vertigineux.
Aujourd'hui, dans la guerre,
l'Ukraine fait montre d'une
indéfectible force.
Mais demain, après la victoire, le
pays retrouvera ses divisions
politiques et culturelles qui
existaient avant le conflit.
Sur ces divisions se poseront les
cicatrices de la guerre.
L'expérience de la résistance aux
forces d'occupation sera présente.
Des tensions pourraient se faire
jour, et avec elles, une forme
d'instabilité.
Comment, dès lors, faire succéder
l'unité dans la paix, la concorde
et la réconciliation?
Comment la France et ses
partenaires européens peuvent-ils
réussir dans l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'Union Européenne, ce
formidable défi de gagner la paix
intérieure?
Comment les autorités françaises,
aux côtés des autorités
ukrainiennes, en lien avec les
partenaires européens,
peuvent-elles anticiper ces défis
essentiels?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
au président Bourlanges
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Jean-Louis Bourlanges:
Madame la présidente, madame la
Première ministre, messieurs et
mesdames les ministres, mes chers
collègues, au-delà de la guerre et du
devoir de solidarité collective,
durable et sans faille, jusqu'à la
libération de ce peuple
et le rétablissement
de sa souveraineté dans son
territoire internationalement
reconnu, au-delà de cela, je
voudrais poser ce qui constitue
pour nous un impératif
catégorique, je voudrais poser ici
la question du sens profond que
revêt à nos yeux la promesse
d'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'Union
Européenne.
Porte-parole d'un groupe
passionnément attaché à la
construction de l'Europe, je vous
invite, madame la Première
ministre, à
tordre le cou à l'idée perverse
selon laquelle cette adhésion
sonnerait le glas de notre
aventure communautaire.
Nous faisons au MoDem le pari
inverse.
Nous attendons ce grand
rendez-vous, un double
enrichissement de notre projet
commun.
L'Ukraine nous apprend par son
courage et son héroïsme que le
droit n'est rien quand la force
n'est pas, que l'exemplarité est
vaine quand l'esprit de résidence
est absent et que l'union ne sera
qu'une apparence si elle ne se
donne pas les moyens d'armer ses
valeurs.
Grâce à vous, chers amis
d'Ukraine, nous faisons enfin
nôtres les paroles prêtées à
Périclès: "Il n'y a pas de bonheur
sans liberté ni de liberté sans
vaillance."
L'Ukraine nous rappelle aux
devoirs de vaillance, mais nous
lui proposons de rejoindre le
monde qui lui a toujours été
refusé, un monde où la force
n'exclut pas le droit, où l'on
sait que l'on ne défend vraiment
ses intérêts légitimes qu'à la
condition de prendre en compte les
intérêts légitimes des autres, un
monde où les gens sans visage, au
lieu de se dévisager,
se parlent, un monde qui n'ignore
pas qu'il n'y ait pas
d'élargissement qui vaille sans un
renforcement des institutions
communes.
C'est la rencontre de ces deux
exigences qui fera de l'Europe un
acteur à part entière.
La princesse
d'Ukraine naguère lointaine est
déjà proche et est de retour parmi
nous.
Puissions-nous l'accueillir pour
ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
vraiment devenue, une immense
figure de résistance qui s'est
donnée pour mission d'arracher nos
peuples désorientés à leur
somnolence historique et qui, pour
parler comme Malraux, porte aux
yeux du monde l'honneur de toute
l'Europe comme un invincible
songe.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
Jean-Louis Bourlanges.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Cyrielle Chatelain.
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Je vous
remercie.
Madame la Première ministre,
monsieur le président, à travers
vous, c'est le peuple ukrainien
que je souhaite saluer.
Vous qui combattez avec courage,
force et détermination l'invasion
russe.
Face à vous, le mythe de la
puissance russe s'est étiolé.
Je tiens à vous assurer de notre
soutien et de notre solidarité.
Dans ce combat, l'Ukraine défend
nos valeurs, la liberté et la
démocratie.
C'est l'honneur de la France
d'avoir pu accueillir celles et
ceux qui ont été arrachés à leur
maison, à leur famille et à leurs
amis.
La Russie de Vladimir Poutine
espérait isoler l'Ukraine de
l'Europe, elle n'a fait que nous
rapprocher.
Nos peuples n'ont jamais été aussi
liés.
Demain, l'Ukraine, qui aura
retrouvé son intégrité
territoriale, sera pleinement
membre de l'Union Européenne.
Face au retour de la guerre,
l'Union Européenne n'a pas failli.
Des sanctions ont été prises.
La solidarité internationale s'est
organisée pour fournir de l'aide
humanitaire et du matériel
militaire.
Cette solidarité est indispensable
à la victoire.
La stratégie de la Russie est de
priver l'Ukraine et les Ukrainiens
de tout.
La Russie les prive d'énergie, de
soins, d'eau potable.
Elle veut également les priver
d'avenir.
La guerre brisent des vies.
C'est tout un peuple qui subit les
bombardements, les tortures, les
viols et la mort.
La guerre empoisonne les terres.
La dispersion de munitions et
l'enfouissement de mines sur plus
de 250 kilomètres carrés
empoisonne les sols les plus
fertiles d'Europe.
La guerre saccage un pays et son
patrimoine.
200.000 ha de forêt ont brûlé.
Un tiers des espaces protégés ont
été abîmé.
Les infrastructures nucléaires
ukrainiennes sont des cibles
répétées, devenues un espace de
conflit, leur sécurité n'est
jamais complètement garantie.
Le nucléaire est un danger pour
l'Ukraine et pour l'Europe.
Le nucléaire est une arme
d'influence également.
Dans un rôle incertain,
l'indépendance énergétique est
cruciale.
Pendant des années, nous avons
fait de Poutine un partenaire
politique en raison de nos
dépendances aux énergies fossiles.
Aujourd'hui, l'uranium russe peut
toujours être un outil de chantage
de la part de la Russie par
l'intermédiaire d'une entreprise.
Nous devons mettre un terme à tout
ce qui nous contraint à la
dépendance envers la Russie.
Madame la Première ministre,
comment comptez-vous libérer la
France de ce levier d'influence
russe, alors que l'uranium a été
exclu de l'embargo à l'encontre de
la Russie?
Comptez-vous enfin émanciper la
France de cet uranium autoritaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Pour terminer, le président
Christophe Naegelen.
- Christophe Naegelen: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
monsieur le président, tout
d'abord, je tenais à saluer le
courage des Ukrainiennes et des
Ukrainiens qui, depuis un an
maintenant, vivent sous une menace
constante.
Ils ont montré au monde entier ce
que l'engagement d'un peuple à
défendre son territoire veut dire.
Depuis février, la Russie a fait
le choix de la guerre.
Elle a fait le choix de
l'escalade.
Depuis, la France est aux côtés de
l'Ukraine.
Elle est aux côtés du droit.
La France est en soutien à un Etat
voisin, ami, en détresse.
Il est normal que la France
prenne, en soutien, toute sa part,
pour l'Ukraine.
C'est que nous faisons depuis le
début de ce conflit, de manière
régulière, de manière suivie.
Nous apportons un soutien
diplomatique, matériel, et nous
affirmons notre sincère solidarité
envers le peuple ukrainien.
Cette aide est nationale, portée
par l'Etat français, mais elle est
aussi à tous les niveaux, toutes
les strates, des collectivités,
des communes, des départements et
des régions.
La région Grand Est en est un
parfait exemple.
En plus de sa diplomatie, en plus
de son aide humanitaire, en plus
de son armement, notre pays
possède une réelle expertise dans
de nombreux autres domaines.
Nous comptons de nombreuses
entreprises françaises dont les
compétences peuvent et doivent
être mises au service de cette
cause.
Il faut mobiliser nos acteurs
économiques afin de venir en aide
à la population civile
ukrainienne, afin de bâtir la
paix.
Après les temps de guerre,
viennent les temps de paix.
Ce sont ces temps que nous
appelons de nos voeux.
Dès maintenant, il faut identifier
les besoins du peuple ukrainien,
viser les secteurs prioritaires,
reconstruire les infrastructures
civiles détruites, qu'il s'agisse
de l'accès à l'énergie, à l'eau,
au secteur agroalimentaire, à
celui de la santé, de l'éducation,
du transport.
Ainsi, madame la Première
ministre, mes questions sont
simples: comment se positionne la
France aujourd'hui pour son
intégration à l'effort et à
l'urgence de reconstruction de
l'Ukraine, maintenant, mais aussi
sur le long, le moyen et le court
terme?
Comment se coordonne-t-elle au
niveau de l'Union Européenne?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le président Rada,
mesdames et messieurs les
présidents et présidentes,
mesdames et messieurs les députés,
il y a près d'un an, la Russie
lançait une offensive sur
l'Ukraine.
Une attaque fondée sur des
mensonges au mépris de toutes les
règles du droit international.
Une attaque brutale et meurtrière.
Depuis près d'un an, l'Ukraine
subit les assauts et les
bombardements russes.
Civils, hôpitaux, écoles, et même
convois humanitaires sont ciblés.
Depuis près d'un an, l'Ukraine
résiste, et repousse les forces
russes.
Monsieur le président
Stefantchouk, je veux saluer votre
présence à l'invitation de la
présidente Yaël Braun-Pivet.
A travers vous, je veux dire mon
respect et mon admiration pour le
courage exceptionnel des forces
armées et du peuple ukrainien.
Applaudissements nourris
Monsieur le président, en
attaquant votre pays, ce sont nos
valeurs que la Russie cherche à
atteindre.
Ce sont les droits humains, la
liberté et la démocratie qu'a
voulu faire plier la Russie.
Nous voulons défendre ces valeurs.
La lâcheté, aujourd'hui,
provoquerait les conflits de
demain.
Comme l'a assuré le président de
la République, nous sommes et nous
resterons avec vous jusqu'à la
victoire.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
le soutien de la France, de
l'Europe et des alliés passe
d'abord par des livraisons
d'armement.
Nous sommes l'un des premiers
contributeurs dans la livraison
d'équipements, de munitions, et la
formation de centaines de soldats
ukrainiens.
Ce sont des équipements qui font
la différence sur le terrain.
Je pense aux canons CAESAR, aux
lance-roquettes unitaires ou encore
aux systèmes antiaériens Crotale.
Début janvier, le président
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé la
livraison de chars légers,
répondant à la demande ukrainienne
en matière de blindés, et lançant
une dynamique.
Depuis, d'autres pays ont annoncé
la livraison de chars à l'Ukraine.
Nous sommes prêts à étudier les
demandes supplémentaires des
Ukrainiens en veillant au respect
de trois principes: d'abord, notre
aide ne doit pas provoquer
d'escalade.
Ensuite, elle doit être utile et
efficace rapidement.
Enfin, elle ne doit pas affaiblir
nos propres capacités de défense.
Des capacités qui augmenteront
significativement ces prochaines
années, comme le proposera la
future loi de programmation
militaire.
Sur ces fondements, le ministre
des Armées étudie les options
possibles.
Chaque pays dispose de domaines
d'excellence, et nous devons nous
coordonner au mieux avec nos
alliés.
Par ailleurs, nous avons créé un
fonds spécial de soutien de 200
millions d'euros pour permettre à
l'Ukraine de commander les
équipements auprès des industriels
français.
Enfin, nous prenons toute notre
part dans la facilité européenne
pour la paix qui aident à équiper
et à former les forces
ukrainiennes.
Notre soutien à l'Ukraine ne se
limite pas à la question des
équipements, loin de là.
Notre réponse face à l'agression,
ce sont également les sanctions
contre la Russie.
En lançant cette guerre, la Russie
pensait diviser l'Union
Européenne.
Elle a échoué.
Au contraire, nous avons fait
bloc.
Moins de 24 heures après
l'attaque, un premier paquet de
sanctions était adopté.
Aujourd'hui, nous en avons adopté
neuf.
Finance, banques, commerce,
propagande, intérêts des
oligarques, ce sont des sanctions
fortes, massives, dans tous les
domaines.
Notre but est de rendre le coût de
la guerre insupportable pour la
Russie.
N'en déplaise aux admirateurs des
régimes forts, ces sanctions
fonctionnent.
Paralysie du système productif,
difficulté à réorienter les
exportations, les difficultés
d'approvisionnement...
La récession russe devrait
atteindre 5,5% en 2023 selon
l'OCDE.
Bien sûr, cette guerre a des
conséquences sur nos compatriotes.
C'est pourquoi nous avons mis en
place des mesures parmi les plus
protectrices d'Europe face à la
montée des prix.
La France est l'un des pays où
l'inflation est la plus faible en
Europe et, avec le gouvernement,
nous continuerons à protéger nos
compatriotes contre les
conséquences du conflit.
Mesdames et messieurs, notre
soutien à l'Ukraine est également
diplomatique.
Il vise à isoler chaque jour
davantage la Russie sur la scène
internationale.
Aujourd'hui, les faits sont là:
l'adoption des résolutions de
l'assemblée générale de l'ONU de
mars et octobre 2022, par une très
large majorité, l'a montré.
J'ajoute que nous avons reconnu
pleinement l'appartenance de
l'Ukraine à la famille européenne.
Je pense notamment à la décision
historique du Conseil européen de
juin qui lui a accordé le statut
de candidat à l'unanimité.
Mais notre soutien est aussi
humanitaire.
Plus de 275 millions d'euros ont
été mobilisés, et 2700 tonnes de
matériel ont été livrés par la
France.
La conférence solidaire avec le
peuple ukrainien, organisée à
l'initiative du président de la
République en décembre dernier à
Paris, a permis de recueillir 1
milliard d'euros d'engagements
nouveaux, concentrés sur l'aide
d'urgence, pour permettre à
l'Ukraine de passer l'hiver.
Pour sa part, la France a donné la
priorité au secteur énergétique,
avec notamment la fourniture de
générateurs électriques de haute
puissance, ou encore de millions
d'ampoules LED à l'Ukraine.
La conférence a également abouti à
la mise en place du mécanisme de
Paris, qui permet de faire le lien
entre les demandes exprimées par
les autorités ukrainiennes et les
dons internationaux.
Ce soutien humanitaire va de pair
avec l'accueil sur notre
territoire de personnes fuyant la
guerre.
Plus de 100.000 ressortissants
ukrainiens ont été accueillis, et
près de 20.000 enfants scolarisés.
Je veux saluer ici la mobilisation
des associations, des ONG, des
collectivités et de nos
concitoyens.
J'ajoute que l'Europe a été au
rendez-vous et la protection
temporaire a été accordée aux
déplacés ukrainiens.
C'était une première.
Enfin, notre soutien, c'est
d'accompagner dès maintenant
la reconstruction de l'Ukraine.
Nous avons décidé de permettre la
reconstruction d'infrastructures.
Une plate-forme réunit désormais
les membres du G7 et les
institutions financières
internationales.
Nous y prenons toute notre part.
En parallèle, et après la
conférence de Berlin d'octobre
dernier, nous avons mobilisé à
Paris plus de 700 entreprises pour
contribuer à la reconstruction du
pays.
Au-delà de notre soutien à
l'Ukraine, notre pays, avec
l'Europe, tient son rang face aux
crises provoquées par ce conflit,
et notamment le risque de pénurie
alimentaire mondiale.
Dès le mois de mars dernier, le
président de la République a pris
les devants en lançant une
initiative pour des corridors de
solidarité mis en place pour
répondre au blocus imposé par la
Russie, et qui a permis d'exporter
plus de 23 millions de tonnes de
produits céréaliers d'Ukraine par
voie terrestre.
Avec les exportations permises par
l'initiative céréalière en mer
Noire, ce sont plus de 37 millions
de tonnes de produits agricoles
qui ont été exportés vers le
marché mondial.
Dans le même temps, nous soutenons
les efforts de la Roumanie en
soutenant les capacités
logistiques de navigation dans les
ports locaux.
Nous livrerons prochainement de
l'aide.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
pour être efficace, notre action
doit être coordonnée.
Sur tous les sujets, elle
s'inscrit dans un cadre européen.
Je me réjouis qu'un sommet entre
l'Union Européenne et l'Ukraine se
tienne ce vendredi 3 février.
Il sera l'occasion de réaffirmer
le caractère inflexible de notre
soutien, qui se chiffre
aujourd'hui à près de 50 milliards
d'euros, tous sujets confondus.
Surtout, ce sommet sera l'occasion
de rappeler notre volonté commune
de poursuivre et d'intensifier
notre action.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
nous resterons aux côtés de
l'Ukraine tout au long du conflit,
mais la paix se construira autour
d'une table de négociation.
Nous saluons et nous soutenons la
proposition de paix en 10 points
du président Zelensky.
Une fois de plus, l'Ukraine
cherche les conditions de la paix
quand la Russie entretient les
conditions de la guerre.
Avec l'Europe, avec les alliés,
nous serons jusqu'au bout aux
côtés des Ukrainiens, pour
défendre nos valeurs, et jusqu'au
bout, nous protégerons les
Français des conséquences de la
guerre.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Merci beaucoup, madame la Première
ministre.
Merci au président Stefantchouk.
Applaudissements nourris
...
Je suis heureuse de souhaiter la
bienvenue à nos deux nouveaux
collègues, élus dimanche dernier,
et je
salue la réélection de monsieur
Bertrand Petit.
Enfin, je vous informe que j'ai
reçu du Conseil constitutionnel
une communication d'une décision
portant annulation d'élections
législatives des 12 et 19 juin
2022 de la 1re circonscription de
l'Ariège dans laquelle Bénédicte
Taurine avait été proclamée élue.
Nous allons à présent commencer
notre séance de questions au
gouvernement stricto sensu.
La parole est à madame Charlotte
Leduc pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Charlotte Leduc: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, chers collègues, ma
question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Vendredi dernier, un collectif
publié une note.
Elle a de quoi nous laisser
perplexes, quand nos concitoyens
sont dans la rue, pour nous dire
que le retrait de la réforme doit
être négociable.
Le déficit est-il artificiellement
gonflé pour justifier la réforme?
Le déficit de notre système de
retraite qui vous sert
d'épouvantail pour justifier de
voler les deux plus belles années
de retraite à l'ensemble des
compatriotes dépend pour une part
significative de l'emploi public.
Plus de masse salariale publique,
c'est plus de cotisations dans les
caisses de retraite des services
territoriaux et hospitaliers.
Entre juin 2021 et septembre 2022,
les projections d'emplois publics
produites par Bercy et transmises
pour réaliser ces calculs ont été
très fortement dégradées.
Ces projections prévoient pour la
fonction publique d'Etat et
territoriale l'impossibilité de
recruter au-delà du remplacement
des départs pendant toute la durée
du quinquennat, soit une
rigidification des recrutements
dans les services publics inédite
depuis 2012.
Concernant les salaires, les
hypothèses retenues par le
gouvernement prévoient un quasi
gel des rémunérations sur toute la
durée du quinquennat.
Donc, avec l'inflation, une baisse
de près de 11% de la rémunération
des fonctionnaires.
Si la masse salariale publique
évoluait de la même façon que la
privée, la moitié du déficit des
retraites serait comblé d'ici
2030.
Madame la Première ministre, je
vous pose la question.
Envisagez-vous de mettre en danger
le fonctionnement de nos services
publics déjà à l'os tout en
rabotant le pouvoir d'achat des
fonctionnaires déjà dans la
galère, ou justifiez-vous votre
réforme par un déficit
artificiellement gonflé et
dramatisé?
Où se situe votre mensonge?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée, permettez-moi d'apporter
une réponse à votre question et de
revenir sur ce qui sous-tend votre
texte.
Vous évoquez les hypothèses en
matière de revalorisation des
agents publics.
D'abord, concernant les hypothèses
d'évolution de la rémunération de
la fonction publique et des
effectifs, en ce qui concerne la
fonction publique territoriale et
la fonction publique hospitalière,
les mêmes hypothèses ont été
retenues.
Il n'y a pas de difficultés
majeures en matière de choix des
hypothèses.
La Caisse des retraites accuse un
déficit de plusieurs milliards
d'euros, alors qu'elle couvre 10%
de la population active et des
retraités.
Pour ce qui concerne la fonction
publique d'Etat, l'argument que
vous déployez ne tient pas.
L'Etat assure l'équilibre du
régime des retraites des
fonctionnaires, à un taux de
cotisation qui est à plus de 75%
pour les agents administratifs et
à plus de 125% pour les personnels
militaires.
Quels que soient les variations de
rémunération des agents publics,
il n'y a pas d'impact sur le seuil
du système des retraites.
Une fois que j'ai dit cela, votre
question me permet de rappeler que
cette réforme est nécessaire.
Nécessaire pour une seule raison:
nous avions, dans les années 70, 3
cotisants pour 1 retraité.
Nous sommes à 1,7 pour 1 retraité.
Cela se traduit dans les chiffres.
Le déficit est à 1,8 milliard
d'euros par an dès 2023, et il va
se creuser pour atteindre 12
milliards d'euros par an en 2027.
Si on ne fait rien,
en 10 ans, c'est 165 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Miller,
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Laure Miller: Madame la
présidente, ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre Christophe
Béchu, en charge de la transition
écologique.
Permettez-moi d'abord d'exprimer
ma fierté d'être à vos côtés pour
la première fois.
Je voudrais exprimer aussi une
forme de satisfaction de voir le
Rassemblement National reculer
dans notre hémicycle.
Je voudrais également exprimer ma
reconnaissance à l'égard des
électeurs de la 2e
circonscription.
C'est un mandat qui m'honore et
qui m'oblige.
Ma question porte sur un domaine
dans lequel nous sommes en
majorité très engagés, celui de la
préservation de l'environnement,
plus particulièrement de
l'amélioration de la qualité de
l'air.
Je vais évoquer la question de la
zone à faible émission.
Les ZFE sont un outil utile pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air sur
nos territoires et sur un
territoire donné.
En tant qu'adjointe au maire de
Reims, j'ai pu mettre en place une
ZFE avec mes collègues, que l'on a
voulue la plus pragmatique et
adaptée à notre territoire.
Pour autant, nous ressentons des
déficiences de nos concitoyens à
l'égard de ces ZFE, une défiance
alimentée par le Rassemblement
National à l'occasion de
l'élection législative.
Ils ont choisi un nouveau cheval
de bataille pour opposer les
Français les uns aux autres, les
ruraux aux habitants de nos
villes, pour opposer les Français
les plus modestes à ceux qui ont
davantage de moyens.
L'amélioration de la qualité de
l'air est un objectif de santé
publique.
La question est claire et simple:
comment peut-on améliorer et
accompagner nos concitoyens dans
la mise en oeuvre de ces ZFE pour
faire en sorte que nos concitoyens
puissent considérer que c'est une
mesure juste d'accompagner les
plus modestes d'entre nous,
d'accompagner aussi les habitants
de notre belle ruralité et pour
faire en sorte que l'on puisse
concilier les deux objectifs de
santé publique et de préservation
de la circulation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée Miller, d'abord,
félicitations d'avoir gagné et,
après avoir été attaquée parce que
vous étiez adjointe à
l'environnement d'une ville qui
avait mis en place une zone à
faible émission, et où le RN n'a
eu de cesse de relater les mêmes
fake news, les mêmes infox, en
expliquant qu'il s'agissait
d'abord d'une mesure pour ennuyer
les Français au lieu de les
protéger!
La manière dont la zone à faible
émissions a été mise en place à
Reims témoigne d'abord de
l'intelligence locale qui a
consisté à faire de la
concertation.
A regarder comment mettre en place
des dérogations pour les personnes
atteintes d'affections longue
durée, pour les déménagements,
pour les artisans, permettant de
montrer que, là où les élus locaux
se sont saisis du sujet, les
fantasmes qui sont véhiculées
autour du nombre de gens qui
seraient interdits d'accéder en
ville ne correspondent pas à la
réalité.
L'enjeu est simple: c'est celui de
préserver la santé de nos
concitoyens tout d'abord.
Vous l'avez rappelé, 47.000 morts
de la pollution atmosphérique, 2 a
3 ans de perte d'espérance de vie.
Même si certains, en plus d'être
climato-sceptiques, sont juste
sceptiques sur les cancers et sur
les types de maladies qui
entraînent la mort de nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles...
L'honneur de la politique, c'est
de protéger les plus fragiles, y
compris quand il s'agit de tordre
le cou à la démagogie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
Un peu de silence, s'il vous
plaît.
La parole est à monsieur Meyer
Habib.
- Meyer Habib: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Vendredi dernier, nous
commémorions le 78e anniversaire
de la libération du camp
d'Auschwitz, Journée
internationale de la commémoration
de la Shoah.
2 millions d'enfants déportés,
gazés, brûlés, victimes de la
barbarie nazie.
Après 2000 ans d'exil, après la
Shoah, le peuple juif revient à
Jérusalem sur sa terre ancestrale.
En 48, l'Etat d'Israël renaît,
habitat démocratique, moral, fort.
L'Etat d'Israël n'est pas une
compensation de la Shoah.
Le sionisme existe depuis 2000
ans.
Si l'Etat d'Israël existait à
cette époque, on n'aurait jamais
eu ce que rêve de refaire le
régime sanguinaire iranien.
Vendredi, un djihadiste a choisi
d'abattre à bout portant sept
civils devant une synagogue à
Jérusalem.
J'ai une pensée pour eux.
Si la France a condamné, la gauche
et certains grands médias parlent
de "colons juifs",
d'ultra-orthodoxes, pour justifier à
demi-mot un terrorisme qui est le
même, qu'il frappe à Paris ou à
Nice.
Pour cette gauche, tuer des juifs,
c'est de la résistance.
Ce sont les mêmes qui accueille en
héros à l'Assemblée nationale un
cadre d'une organisation
terroriste, responsable de
l'attentat de la rue Copernic et
qui a ensanglanté la France,
célébré dans le temple de notre
démocratie, un terroriste qui a
affirmé avoir préparé un attentat
sur le Grand rabbin d'Israël.
Madame la Première ministre, ne
trouvez-vous pas intolérable cette
visite à l'Assemblée nationale?
Quels sont les gestes forts que
notre pays compte apporter au
gouvernement israélien dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, je comprends
votre émotion.
Je la partage.
Vendredi dernier, une synagogue a
été ciblée par un Palestinien
radicalisé dans une attaque
abjecte, jour de shabbat, au
sortir de la prière, et le jour
des cérémonies de commémoration
internationale en mémoire des
victimes de la Shoah.
La France a aussitôt condamné cet
attentat dans les termes les plus
clairs.
Nos pensées vont aujourd'hui aux
familles des victimes et aux
blessés.
Certains groupes terroristes, en
Palestine et ailleurs, ont célébré
cette attaque dans une posture de
haine.
Cela ne résoudra rien, au
contraire.
Semaine après semaine, nous
assistons en Israël et dans les
territoires occupés, à une très
grave escalade des tensions.
On ne compte plus les actes de
violence sur les victimes.
Poursuivre la trajectoire actuelle
ne peut mener qu'à davantage
d'affrontements, davantage de
morts.
Il est indispensable d'infléchir
cette trajectoire.
La France réitère donc qu'elle est
déterminée à oeuvrer à la paix,
sur la base du droit international
et de la solution à deux Etats, la
seule qui permettra aux Israéliens
et aux Palestiniens de vivre en
paix et en sécurité comme ils en
ont le droit.
Ce message constant, que la France
émet, le président de la
République le répétera au Premier
ministre israélien.
Je le répéterai aussi dans les
pays de la région où je me rendrai
cette semaine.
Il est autant urgent que
nécessaire de restaurer un horizon
holistique qui manque aujourd'hui
cruellement.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Astrid
Panosyan-Bouvet.
- Astrid Panosyan-Bouvet: Cette
question s'adresse à madame la
ministre Isabelle Rome.
Avec mes collègues, nous saluons
le lancement du plan national de
lutte contre le racisme,
l'antisémitisme et les
discriminations, lancé par la
Première ministre, que
vous avez la magnifique mission de
conduire.
Le 20 janvier dernier, le conseil
scientifique de la délégation
interministérielle à la lutte
contre le racisme, l'antisémitisme
et l'homophobie a été dissous par
sa déléguée.
Ce conseil, composé
d'universitaires, avait pour objet
d'éclairer les politiques mises en
place.
Il a été traversé depuis mai 2022
par de multiples tensions sur les
questions de transidentité liées à
l'appartenance de son président à
l'observatoire de la Petite
Sirène, association jugée
transphobe par certains membres du
conseil scientifique, qui a été
fondé par deux psychanalystes qui
dénoncent régulièrement les
dérives potentielles du
transgenrisme chez les mineurs.
S'il est tout à fait possible
d'être en désaccord avec les
positions de cet observatoire, il
ne semble pas que le débat ait eu
lieu.
La déléguée l'a même porté sans
succès sur le terrain légal en les
signalant au parquet.
L'accusation de transphobie dont
font l'objet les deux
psychanalystes est double.
Elle soulève un problème
spécifique qui est celui des
mineurs.
Doit-on considérer le désir de
transition d'un enfant comme
indiscutable au point d'accéder à
une demande de médicalisation aux
conséquences potentiellement
irréversibles, ou bien doit-on
mettre des conditions?
C'est tout le débat au nom de
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant,
principe à valeur
constitutionnelle.
Cette dissolution interroge aussi
sur le respect des libertés
académiques, et plus largement sur
la protection de la liberté
d'expression.
Pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur
cette dissolution?
Nous comptons sur vous pour que le
combat déterminé contre le
racisme, l'antisémitisme et la
haine anti-LGBT déployée dans ce
plan national puisse se poursuivre
dans la cohérence avec notre idéal
républicain et universaliste?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Isabelle
Rome.
- Isabelle Rome: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, vous
m'interrogez sur un grand sujet,
qui nous tient particulièrement à
coeur, et sur lequel nous
concentrons toute notre énergie.
C'est celui de la lutte contre le
racisme, l'antisémitisme et les
discriminations.
Il nous revient de les traquer
inlassablement, car ils entaillent
notre pacte social fondé sur
l'universalisme.
Un universalisme républicain et
donc humaniste.
Pas un universalisme dévoyé, qui
nie l'existence d'un monde
pluriel, l'universalisme auquel
nous aspirons est celui qui offre
à chacune et chacun la dignité qui
lui revient.
La Première ministre
a lancé un plan de 80 mesures
concrètes que je suis fière de
piloter aux côtés des ministres et
d'une majorité engagée.
Rapidement, maintenant, sur la
question de la dissolution du
conseil scientifique que vous
évoquez, il ne reposait sur aucun
cadre juridique, n'était encadré
ni dans sa composition ni dans ses
missions, et force est de
constater qu'il ne produisait plus
grand-chose depuis plusieurs mois.
Dans la lutte face à notre ennemi
commun, seule l'efficacité
importe.
C'est donc pour nous appuyer plus
efficacement sur la communauté
scientifique que nous avons choisi
de renouveler les modalités de
travail avec les chercheurs, dans
la diversité des expertises.
Nous avons la même ambition pour
le futur plan de lutte contre la
haine anti-LGBT plus.
Face aux haines, je serai toujours
intraitable.
Face à toutes les haines,
racismes, antisémitismes,
homophobie, transphobie...
Pas de hiérarchie.
Vous pouvez compter sur ma
détermination pour les combattre
sans relâche.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame
Marie-France Lorho.
- Marie-France Lorho: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, chers
collègues, ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre.
Vous avez qualifié votre réforme
de réforme de justice.
Selon le nouvel âge légal de 64
ans qu'elle introduit, que
répondez-vous à tous les salariés
qui atteindront leurs 43 annuités
à 62 ans et qui devront travailler
deux ans de plus que les autres?
Ce sont aussi les mères de
famille, les ouvriers, les
employés et tous les travailleurs
de seconde ligne, qui sont souvent
des femmes, qui devront travailler
deux ans de plus.
Vous avez également qualifié votre
réforme de réforme de progrès.
Or vous faites peser l'essentiel
des efforts sur la classe moyenne.
En quoi est-ce un progrès?
Plus les débats avancent, plus les
Français découvrent la réalité de
votre réforme, et, assez
logiquement, plus ils y sont
opposés.
Les manifestations du jour
l'illustrent.
Ce ne sont pas les dépenses de
retraite qui posent problème, mais
bien les recettes.
C'est la conséquence directe de
vos politiques.
Comme si cela ne suffisait pas,
après avoir délocalisé l'industrie
française et ses emplois, après
avoir détruit la productivité,
base de notre modèle de retraite
par répartition, le gouvernement
continue de tirer les salaires
vers le bas avec le futur texte
sur l'immigration et son titre de
séjour aggravant la paupérisation
de notre pays et de nos
travailleurs, puisque nous avons
appris, il y a quelques jours,
des chiffres illustrant votre
politique migratoire.
En 2022, les motifs économiques
sont en hausse de plus de 45% et
les régularisations de
sans-papiers, en hausse de 8%.
Derrière le lobby des fonds de
pension, pourriez-vous écouter
l'appel à l'aide des Français en
leur épargnant cette réforme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée, vous interrogez madame la
Première ministre et le
gouvernement sur la réforme des
retraites et sur le relèvement
progressif de l'âge à l'ouverture
des droits de 62 à 64 ans.
Est-ce que c'est un effort?
Oui, c'est demandé aux Français
pour garantir la pérennité du
système par répartition.
C'est un effort de travail
supplémentaire.
L'objectif que nous poursuivons
depuis le début des concertations
avec la Première ministre, c'est
de faire en sorte que cet effort
soit bien réparti.
Vous avez évoqué la durée de
cotisation.
Vous avez évoqué une génération en
demandant ce que nous répondons à
ceux qui devront peut-être cotiser
plus longtemps que la durée
exigée.
C'est une situation que nous
connaissons déjà.
Aujourd'hui, dans le système tel
que nous le connaissons, nous
avons chaque année 800.000 départs
à la retraite.
Sur ces 800.000 départs à la
retraite, de nombreux assurés ont
un nombre d'années supérieur à ce
qui est requis.
Lorsque nous nous retournons
quelque peu sur le passé, avant la
création des carrières longues,
l'âge de départ à la retraite
était fixé à 60 ans.
La durée de cotisation était de 37
ans et demi.
Certaines personnes partaient à 60
ans et demi après avoir cotisé
autant d'années qu'il le fallait.
D'autres partaient à 60 ans en
ayant cotisé plus.
Depuis, chaque réforme a permis de
diviser l'écart entre le minimum
de cotisation requis et la durée
de cotisation faite par un certain
nombre d'assurés.
Il y a parfois dans le débat une
facilité qui consisterait à
imaginer que la durée de
cotisation requise est un plafond.
C'est en réalité un plancher parce
que, dans notre système, depuis
qu'il a été créé, la durée de
cotisation pour avoir droit à un
taux plein est une durée plancher.
Nous avons maintenant un quart des
assurés qui travaillent déjà plus
que cette durée de cotisation.
Cela fait partie de ce système.
Tout ce que nous avons fait, c'est
de réduire au maximum l'écart pour
établir un maximum d'égalité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Delphine
Lingemann.
- Delphine Lingemann: Madame la
présidente, chers collègues, ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
la Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires.
Je souhaite y associer ma collègue
Laurence Vichnievsky.
Le prochain rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures
sur la période 2023-2032 est très
attendu, à tel point que certains
extraits sont d'ores et déjà
connus.
L'Auvergne est le territoire
métropolitain le plus mal relié à
la capitale sur le plan
ferroviaire: 3h30 pour relier
Clermont-Ferrand à Paris quand
tout va bien.
En effet, de nombreuses
défaillances techniques liées au
vieillissement du matériel roulant
et des infrastructures provoquent
des retards fréquents, soulevant
la colère des usagers.
Ils sont victimes de décennies de
sous-investissements structurels
et de promesses d'investissements
non tenues.
L'axe ferroviaire Clermont-Paris
fait pourtant partie des trois
lignes structurantes des trains
d'équilibre des territoires.
L'Etat s'est engagé financièrement
à hauteur de 760 millions d'euros
jusqu'en 2026, mais pour diverses
raisons, des retards sont pris sur
la régénération de la ligne et la
livraison de nouvelles rames.
Agir au plus tôt pour garantir une
ligne de qualité durable et
efficace est une question de
survie pour notre territoire.
Selon le rapport, l'engagement de
l'Etat semblerait se terminer en
2026.
Or nous avons besoin de poursuivre
les investissements pour
moderniser la ligne et faire
passer le temps de trajet à 2h30.
La grande vertu de ce rapport sera
de mettre sur table une liste de
priorités et une nouvelle
programmation, c'est ce qu'avait
déclaré le ministre des Transports
le 5 octobre dernier au Sénat.
Est-ce que la ligne structurante
Clermont-Paris fait partie des
priorités de l'Etat au-delà de
2026?
Est-elle inscrite dans un
programme de modernisation?
Si tel est le cas, pouvez-vous
nous apporter des éléments de
précision?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
députée, j'ai le plaisir de vous
répondre, en l'absence de Clément
Beaune, que vous aviez interpellé.
Je vais vous rappeler que le 24
février, dans quelques jours, le
comité annuel de suivi va se
réunir à nouveau, et désormais, un
comité régulier de suivi, pas
seulement tous les ans, existe.
Après une visite à Clermont et à
Vichy pour faire en sorte de
coordonner l'ensemble des actions,
Clément Beaune a pris l'engagement
de vous tenir régulièrement
informés de là où nous en sommes
par rapport au retard que vous
évoquez.
C'est 1,1 milliard d'euros qui
sont prévus pour le soutien à la
régénération et à l'amélioration
du confort des usagers.
Les rames ont vocation à toutes
être livrées en 2026, avec la
première nouvelle rame qui
arrivera en circulation dès 2025.
Malgré les incidents liés à ces
retards de régénération, la
régularité s'est améliorée sur le
premier semestre.
Nous sommes à 86% contre 78% sur
le semestre précédent.
Evidemment, ce sont ces travaux de
régénération qui permettront
d'être enfin à l'échelle de la
ligne structurante que vous
évoquez.
Vous avez évoqué le rapport du
Comité des infrastructures et le
travail piloté en particulier par
votre collègue.
Sa remise dans les prochains jours
est imminente et permettra à ce
moment-là d'expliquer la
méthodologie et le suivi avec
lesquels le gouvernement entend y
répondre.
Il ne vous a pas échappé qu'il y a
à l'intérieur des propositions qui
sont structurantes, une ambition
qui est cohérente avec la
transition écologique et avec le
besoin de proximité des
territoires et de faire en sorte
de les rapprocher et d'améliorer
leur confort.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Antoine
Léaument.
- Antoine Léaument: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Economie, ce 1er
février, les péages d'autoroutes
vont augmenter de près de 5%.
Face à ce racket, les gilets
jaunes de Lyon font aujourd'hui
une opération péage gratuit, et je
les soutiens.
Pour reprendre les mots de la CGT
Energie de Marseille, c'est
illégal mais moral.
Selon Le Canard enchaîné, un
rapport vous a été remis il y a
deux ans.
Il préconisait de baisser les prix
des péages de 60%.
Vous l'avez gardé secret.
Vous avez déclaré au MEDEF: "Un
superprofit, je ne sais pas ce que
c'est."
Voici ce que c'est: en 2021, ces
sociétés d'autoroutes ont réalisé
3,9 milliards d'euros de profit.
Que font ces entreprises de ces
superprofits?
Augmentent-elles les salaires?
Non, elles donnent tout aux
actionnaires.
85% des bénéfices en 2021.
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a raison: oui,
accumuler ces milliards sur le dos
des Français est immoral.
Oui, ces actionnaires sont des
parasites.
Voici mes trois questions.
Vous engagez-vous à rendre public
le rapport sur les sociétés
d'autoroutes que vous gardez
secret?
Avez-vous personnellement, parmi
les membres de votre gouvernement,
des conflits d'intérêts avec ces
entreprises, ce qui expliquerait
un tel laxisme?
Allez-vous faire cesser le racket
des automobilistes?
Troisième question, monsieur le
ministre, et un conseil:
renationalisez les autoroutes,
comme le proposait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon.
77% des Français y sont
favorables.
Faites respecter l'intérêt général
et la volonté du peuple contre
l'intérêt privé et l'égoïsme des
riches.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: J'ai bien noté
que votre question s'adressait à
monsieur Bruno Le Maire.
Je vais vous apporter une réponse
au sujet que vous évoquez.
Oui, le 1er février, conformément
aux clauses prévues dans les
contrats, il y aura une
augmentation des péages, puisque
ces contrats prévoient une
indexation qui n'est pas
totalement répercutée compte tenu
de ce que le gouvernement a
souhaité.
Ce sera 5% de baisse au titre de
la transition écologique.
J'ai compris que l'essentiel de
votre question n'était pas
là-dessus.
L'enjeu, et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce rapport avait été
demandé, c'est de faire en sorte
d'obtenir davantage de fiscalité
de la part des autoroutes.
Nous avons deux contentieux
pendants devant les tribunaux.
Nous en avons un sur l'indexation
des aménagements du territoire.
Nous avons gagné une première
manche le 13 janvier dernier.
Le deuxième, c'est sur la taxe
exceptionnelle sur les
contributions autoroutières.
Dans ce contexte, ce rapport sert
à accompagner les arguments du
gouvernement.
Il est donc couvert par le
contentieux en cours, ce qui
explique qu'il n'ait pas été
publié.
L'enjeu, pour nous, c'est d'aller
chercher l'argent dans le cadre de
ces profits qui sont importants,
avec une obsession qui est la fin
des concessions.
Quand vous dites que la solution
serait de nationaliser les
autoroutes, ça veut dire que vous
souhaitez que l'on mette 40
milliards d'euros d'argent public
pour acheter des autoroutes, et
ensuite faire en sorte que nous
financions la route.
Ce n'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
procéder au titre de la transition
écologique.
Il faut au contraire faire en
sorte de prélever l'argent sur les
autoroutes pour être capable de
financer le ferroviaire en
particulier.
Les sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroutes sont les premières
contributrices à ce titre.
- Antoine Léaument: Vous devriez
suivre les recommandations du
rapport, alors!
Vous devriez récupérer les
sociétés d'autoroutes en 2026 ou
les taxer!
Vous êtes en train d'attendre!
Vous rendez l'Etat impuissant!
Un peu de bonne volonté!
Les Français se font racketter, il
y en a ras le bol!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Henri Alfandari.
- Henri Alfandari: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Education nationale,
alors que les arbitrages relatifs
aux moyens d'enseignement occupent
activement les services de
l'Education nationale, les
suppressions de postes à venir
pour la rentrée prochaine sont une
source d'angoisse pour les
communautés éducatives rurales.
En effet, ces suppressions de
postes viennent percuter les
efforts conduits par les
collectivités rurales et les
services déconcentrés de votre
ministère.
Le stade expérimental des
territoires éducatifs ruraux, qui
ne concerne que trois académies,
les suppressions des moyens
d'enseignement et les réalités en
matière de mobilité pour les
enseignants sur notre territoire
interrogent.
Nous ne pouvons pas faire
disparaître nos ruralités.
Elles se renouvellent toujours
davantage dans leurs modes
d'organisation pour répondre aux
nombreux défis qui se présentent à
elles.
L'école est au coeur des
préoccupations des élus ruraux.
Elle est souvent la colonne
vertébrale des politiques
déployées au service de la
cohésion et de l'attractivité des
territoires.
L'école rurale est un levier
essentiel pour accompagner
l'égalité des chances que vous
portez et pour permettre aux
enfants et aux familles de
construire sereinement leur
avenir.
Ainsi, monsieur le ministre, ne
serait-il pas temps de réexaminer
un certain nombre de critères qui
conduisent aux fermetures de
classes, notamment le critère de
nombre d'élèves par classe?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Monsieur le député, depuis la
rentrée 2019, comme vous le savez,
aucune fermeture d'école ne peut
intervenir sans l'accord du maire.
Par ailleurs, comme vous l'avez
indiqué, nous faisons face à une
baisse démographique importante de
90.000 à 100.000 élèves de moins
chaque année, pour un total
d'environ un demi-million d'élèves
sur l'ensemble du quinquennat.
Dans votre département
d'Indre-et-Loire, ce sont 756
élèves en moins que nous aurons à
la rentrée 2023.
Néanmoins, la suppression de
postes ne se fait pas de manière
arithmétique.
Le taux d'encadrement en général
va continuer à s'améliorer.
Nous sommes à 22,3 dans votre
département, et nous allons tendre
vers les 22 élèves par classe.
En effet, les territoires ruraux
ne sont pas traités de la même
manière.
Nous tenons compte du fait que les
services publics ne sont pas
disposés de la même manière, et
nous prêtons une attention
particulière à leur situation.
On est parfois obligé de regrouper
plusieurs niveaux dans les mêmes
classes, tout en veillant à
maintenir le chiffre d'environ 24
élèves par classe pour les grandes
sections, les CP et les CE1.
Enfin, à ce stade, nous en sommes
encore au début des évaluations du
processus pour la rentrée 2023.
Je sais que vous êtes en lien
régulier avec les instances de
votre département.
Des évolutions vont encore se
faire.
Nous sommes donc actuellement dans
un processus.
Rien n'est définitif.
Le dialogue avec les élus locaux
est maintenu.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Sandrine
Rousseau.
- Sandrine Rousseau: Madame la
Première ministre, j'étais tout à
l'heure place d'Italie, dans ma
circonscription, et il y avait
vraiment beaucoup de monde.
Bien sûr, j'ai discuté avec les
gens là-bas.
Ils et elles avaient des questions
pour vous.
Elles étaient intéressantes.
Ca vaudrait le coup que vous les
entendiez, que vous les écoutiez,
et même que vous y répondiez.
Vous savez ce que c'est, cette
sagesse de la rue.
C'est un vrai truc.
Lisa avait une question:
croyez-vous vraiment que les gens
de plus de 55 ans au RSA
retrouveront du travail pour
cotiser?
Je précise qu'elle ne parlait pas
des 15 à 20 heures de travail
gratuit que vous imposez, mais
d'un vrai travail avec un vrai
salaire.
Il y avait aussi Pierre: pourquoi
ce serait aux petites gens de
payer pour que les retraites
soient à l'équilibre?
Bonne question.
Thomas: avez-vous repéré que dans
un système comptable, il y avait
des dépenses, mais aussi des
recettes?
Thomas est économiste, alors
forcément...
Robin: je fais mes études, mais au
rythme où ça va, j'ai peur de
mourir avant ma retraite.
Pourquoi ne pas prendre l'argent
où il est?
Karine: pourquoi le gouvernement
dit que ce truc se fait pour
l'intérêt de tous alors que ça
touche uniquement les plus
précaires, les carrières hachées
et les carrières longues?
Nicolas: au sujet du handicap,
est-ce que les RQTH seront
concernés par les trimestres
supplémentaires?
Nathalie demande comment sont
comptées les années de travail des
sans-papiers.
Lina: quand est-ce qu'on arrête
les 49.3?
Valérie: je n'ai pas envie de
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans.
Comment je fais?
Marie-Pierre, 83 ans, voulait que
vous vous souveniez qu'avant, vous
étiez socialiste.
Pourquoi avoir changé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
S'il vous plaît!
C'est fini.
Un peu de silence!
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Madame la députée Rousseau, je
note que vous avez besoin qu'on
vous aide à poser vos questions.
Je note que dans les questions que
vous faites mine de relayer ici,
vous ne faites qu'écho aux
désinformations, aux mensonges que
vous ne cessez de proférer sur la
réforme des retraites.
Je note une différence entre nous
et vous.
Je suis sûr que madame Rousseau va
prendre plaisir à écouter la fin
de ma réponse.
Je note une grande différence
entre vous et les bancs de cette
majorité.
Elle ne tient qu'en un mot:
responsabilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur...
S'il vous plaît!
La parole est à monsieur Kévin
Pfeffer pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Kévin Pfeffer: Maltraitance par
négligence, rationnement de la
nourriture et des équipements de
soins, manque de personnel,
détournement de fonds publics...
Il y a un an éclatait le scandale
Orpea de la gestion de nos EHPAD.
Les membres du gouvernement et les
députés de la majorité défilaient
alors sur les plateaux, larmes aux
yeux, pour nous promettre qu'il y
aurait un avant et un après, mais
de l'aveu du président de
l'Observatoire du grand âge, en un
an, rien n'a changé.
Les contrôles sont faits à la
va-vite.
Rien de nouveau pour nos anciens,
toujours en grande difficulté.
Vous avez annoncé que les
inspections devraient couvrir les
7500 établissements français d'ici
2024, mais avec seulement 18
contrôlés à ce jour, l'objectif ne
sera pas tenu.
Pire, il n'existe toujours aucun
référentiel comme base de
contrôle, et le syndicat des
directeurs d'EHPAD fait ce
terrible constat: le plus souvent,
on nous demande d'envoyer par
e-mail des documents comptables et
administratifs.
Alors que la maltraitance
continue, vous avez refusé une
proposition de loi de bon sens
permettant d'étendre le droit de
vie dans nos EHPAD.
Le taux d'encadrement moyen de
trois soignants pour 10 résidents
est au centre du problème.
Dans son rapport publié
mi-janvier, la défenseure des
droits réaffirme qu'en dessous de
huit encadrants, on ne peut pas
travailler sans maltraitance.
Ce n'est pas le PLFSS 2023 qui
résoudra ce problème.
Combien de lanceurs d'alerte,
combien de signalements par
plate-forme numérique et combien
de rapports vous faudra-t-il
encore?
La loi sur le grand âge se fait
attendre depuis 25 ans.
Quand est-ce que nos aînés seront
enfin mieux considérés?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Monsieur
le député, vous l'avez rappelé, il
y a un an, la publication des
"Fossoyeurs" a provoqué un choc de
conscience chez l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes.
Ce choc a été terrible et il a été
suivi d'une réponse puissante de
la part des pouvoirs publics, une
réponse puissante pour éradiquer
de nos établissements, de nos
EHPAD, mais aussi des activités à
domicile des actes scandaleux qui
ont été à nouveau rappelés il y a
quelques jours dans un certain
nombre de reportages.
Cette réponse puissante est passée
d'abord par une série de contrôles
de l'ensemble de nos EHPAD.
400 EHPAD ont été contrôlés
immédiatement après le choc et la
publication des "Fossoyeurs".
Plus de 1400 ont été contrôlés à
ce jour.
Les 7500 que compte notre pays le
seront d'ici à la fin de l'année
2024.
Ces contrôles ont donné lieu à des
réponses fortes: plus de 1800
injonctions, 11 saisines du
procureur de la République.
Il faut maintenant que les choses
s'accélèrent pour faire en sorte
que les choses changent de façon
concrète dans l'ensemble de nos
EHPAD.
J'ai fait de la question de la
maltraitance dans ces
établissements une priorité de mon
action.
Je lancerai dans quelques jours
les états généraux de la lutte
contre la maltraitance pour réunir
l'ensemble des parties prenantes,
ainsi qu'une plate-forme de
signalement, parce qu'il est
important, comme l'ont fait les
lanceurs d'alerte, que la parole
puisse se libérer dans les
établissements et que les familles
puissent signaler l'ensemble de
ces maltraitances.
C'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui.
Après, pour faire face au
vieillissement de la population,
notre pays doit s'organiser, grâce
notamment aux 9 milliards d'euros
qui sont inscrits dans la
trajectoire de la branche
autonomie, grâce au lancement du
recrutement de 50.000
professionnels soignants dans nos
EHPAD pour les cinq ans qui
viennent, grâce au nombre de
places qui sera augmenté dans les
services de soins infirmiers à
domicile.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Mathieu Lefèvre.
- Mathieu Lefèvre: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer.
Demain, la ville de Lyon
s'apprêtait à accueillir; à
l'initiative de son maire, un
sinistre personnage.
D'autres villes n'hésitent pas à
mettre à l'honneur un individu qui
a été reconnu coupable
d'appartenance à une entreprise
collective en vue de commettre des
actions terroristes sur le
territoire israélien.
Ce renoncement salutaire, nous le
devons à des héros, comme le
dernier rescapé d'Auschwitz vivant
à Lyon, qui a protesté contre sa
venue.
Si la France a condamné son
expulsion par l'Etat d'Israël et
défend son droit à un procès
équitable, sa participation à ce
simulacre de conférence aurait été
un scandale.
Oui, c'eût été un scandale que de
prendre prétexte d'une pseudo
conférence universitaire pour
réhabiliter un homme condamné par
l'Etat d'Israël pour sa
participation à la tentative
d'assassinat du grand rabbin.
C'eût été un scandale parce qu'on
ne met pas impunément à l'honneur
un homme dont les liens avec une
organisation classée comme
terroriste par l'Union Européenne
sont avérés.
Cette banalisation de la haine
n'est hélas que le dernier épisode
d'une tentative de réhabilitation
de cet individu par une partie de
cet hémicycle qui, dans
l'indécence la plus totale, a osé
comparer son extradition à une
déportation, n'hésitant pas à
l'acclamer à sa descente d'avion
ou à le recevoir au sein de notre
institution, la déshonorant de sa
présence.
Ma question est simple: quelles
mesures le gouvernement peut-il
prendre afin de protéger les
Français en général?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, vous avez raison,
heureusement que monsieur le maire
de Lyon a renoncé à la mise à
l'honneur et à la participation de
cette triste personnalité.
Je crois que les appels de sa
propre population, notamment lors
de la commémoration de ce
week-end, mais aussi de la
représentante de l'Etat, ont été
entendus.
Nous avons dit que si cette
conférence était maintenue, elle
serait interdite par l'Etat pour
menace à l'ordre public.
Il est heureux que le maire ait
renoncé à ce projet mortifère.
Il ne peut y avoir en aucun cas un
doute sur la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme dans notre pays.
Je veux également souligner votre
action, monsieur le député, comme
président de l'association contre
l'antisémitisme.
C'est un quart d'actes antisémites
au moins qui ont eu lieu en 2022.
Il ne faut pas crier victoire.
Encore 430 actes antisémites ont
eu lieu en 2022, des attaques
contre des lieux de culte, contre
des écoles confessionnelles, et
d'innombrables insultes et
ignominies sur les réseaux
sociaux.
Devant la mobilisation de toute la
France, parce que c'est le
problème de tous les Français et
pas simplement de nos concitoyens
juifs, 1500 cyberpatrouilleurs
seront au rendez-vous de la loi
que vous avez votée.
C'est aussi le cas de l'ouverture
24 heures sur 24 de Pharos, qui
permet de signaler la haine en
ligne.
Et bien sûr, la protection de tous
les lieux de culte juifs et des
écoles qui ont malheureusement
connu le terrorisme.
Aidez-nous à travailler ensemble
contre l'antisémitisme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Mansour Kamardine.
- Mansour Kamardine: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, le
président Eric Ciotti a exprimé sa
volonté d'accompagner le
gouvernement dans une réforme des
retraites qui soit juste, en
particulier pour les petites
retraites.
Si pour le gouvernement, la
réforme concerne le territoire
métropolitain, pour le groupe LR,
la réforme concerne aussi les
ultramarins.
Les ultramarin partent en moyenne
plus tard en retraite, reçoivent
des pensions plus faibles et
meurent plus jeunes.
Encore sur ce territoire, la
retraite moyenne est, pour une
période complète,
20% en-dessous de la moyenne
nationale.
Pire encore, à Mayotte, la pension
moyenne est de 276 euros, alors
que l'allocation de solidarité
pour les personnes âgées est
plafonnée pour des raisons que
j'ignore à 50% de celles de droit
commun.
La réforme des retraites est donc
une occasion à saisir pour
améliorer deux situations
spécifiques.
Le système des retraites à Mayotte
et les petites retraites agricoles
outre-mer, notamment aux Antilles.
C'est pourquoi le groupe LR vous
propose de mettre en place un
dispositif de rachat de trimestre
à un prix raisonnable pour les
agriculteurs ultramarins, de
supprimer sans délai la
suppression de la décote de 50% à
Mayotte et de porter la pension à
Mayotte au moins de 276 à 400
euros.
Je vous demande de dire des
initiatives que vous envisagez de
prendre pour répondre à vos
propositions et améliorer le sort
des retraités d'outre-mer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Vous évoquez la
situation des retraites
d'outre-mer.
Vous avez raison de souligner
combien ce régime créé des
différences.
Il y a plusieurs aspects dans
votre question.
Il y a d'abord la question des
salariés de l'agriculture.
Nous avons un défi qui est de
faire en sorte qu'au-delà du
régime général, la mise en place
du régime complémentaire pour les
salariés du secteur de
l'agriculture doit être une
priorité, mais qui relève de la
discussion entre les partenaires
sociaux.
Ce sont eux qui assurent la
gouvernance.
Nous pouvons y travailler ensemble
pour un travail de conviction et
pour faire en sorte que ces
salariés de l'agriculture dans les
territoires d'outre-mer puissent
être mieux couverts et justement
couverts.
Vous avez aussi évoqué la question
des retraités à Mayotte.
Un régime obligatoire qui n'existe
que depuis 1987, l'absence de
régime complémentaire obligatoire,
une durée de cotisation qui est
particulièrement basse...
Aujourd'hui, nous n'avons que 2500
bénéficiaires du système de
retraite pour un montant de
retraite de 287 euros, ce qui est
extrêmement bas.
Certains dispositifs ont été
adaptés.
Vous avez évoqué une question,
mais il y a aussi un mode de
calcul parfois plus favorable pour
l'accès à un certain nombre de
prestations, notamment en validant
d'office un certain nombre de
trimestres entre 1997 et 2002.
Il y a aussi une période analysée
en termes de trimestre.
La question de Mayotte n'est pas
traitée de manière particulière.
Nous avons fait le choix de ne pas
appliquer la réforme telle qu'elle
aujourd'hui au territoire de
Mayotte.
Cela ne signifie pas que nous ne
devons pas travailler.
Nous devons voir comment nous
pouvons améliorer cette situation,
mieux protéger les retraités et
faire en sorte que cette
convergence puisse être
revalorisée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Mansour Kamardine: Juste pour
dire à monsieur le ministre toute
notre disposition pour travailler
pendant ce débat.
Ca ne peut pas être après.
Vous nous avez fait beaucoup de
promesses qui n'ont pas été
tenues.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Aurélie
Trouvé.
- Aurélie Trouvé: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, avant
que vous partiez, c'est une
journée historique, de celles qui
redonnent au peuple sa puissance.
Nous sommes des millions dans la
rue et la colère monte encore
contre votre réforme.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
rabâchez que cette réforme n'est
plus négociable.
Vous pariez sur le passage en
force contre l'avis de l'immense
majorité des Français, contre tous
les syndicats de salariés.
Passage en force en étouffant la
démocratie parlementaire par un
49.3 déguisé.
Comme vous n'avez plus d'arguments
valables, vous tombez dans la
grossièreté et l'insulte.
Votre ministre de l'Intérieur
renvoie les opposants de la
réforme aux rois fainéants.
A qui parlez-vous ainsi?
A tous les travailleurs essentiels
qui tiennent ce pays depuis deux
ans?
Vous n'avez pas compris!
C'est la France du travail qui est
dans la rue.
C'est la France du travail qui
use.
Ceux qui se lèvent à 4h du matin
pour faire le ménage des
bureaux de La Défense, celle qui
ne pourra pas tenir deux ans de
plus.
Nous aimons le travail, mais le
travail dignement rémunéré, le
travail qui redonne du sens, le
travail qui offre une retraite
heureuse.
C'est vrai, nous n'aimons pas le
travail exploité, celui qui
nourrit les profits
d'actionnaires, et c'est pour cela
que nous n'aimons pas votre
réforme.
Vous nous dites que la grève est
irresponsable.
Vous n'avez sans doute jamais fait
grève.
Savez-vous ce que c'est que de
perdre une journée de salaire?
C'est un choix responsable et
grave.
Vous produisez le chaos.
C'est vous et vous seule qui êtes
responsable du blocage du pays!
Car le peuple résiste et refuse
d'être écrasé une fois de plus.
Vous êtes seule et nous sommes des
millions.
Jusqu'où irez-vous pour imposer
votre projet funeste?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, vous le savez,
mais comme votre argumentaire
n'est pas nouveau, ma réponse ne
sera pas nouvelle.
Cette réforme est nécessaire.
Le système est structurellement
déficitaire.
Je l'ai dit tout à l'heure.
Ce sont 150 milliards d'euros de
déficit cumulé sur les 10 années
qui viennent.
C'est un déficit annuel de 12,5
milliards d'euros par an en 2027,
de 20 milliards d'euros en 2035.
Nous avons la volonté que cet
effort soit le plus justement
réparti.
Nous le faisons avec l'aménagement
des carrières longues, avec la
prise en compte de la pénibilité.
Bien nombreux parmi les exemples
que vous avez cités sont ceux qui
vont pouvoir bénéficier de
l'amélioration du compte
professionnel de prévention, mais
aussi de la meilleure prise en
compte des critères ergonomiques
sur les postures pénibles, sur les
vibrations, sur le port de charges
lourdes.
Nombreux sont ceux qui vont
bénéficier du redressement de
retraite minimum.
Il y a des progrès sociaux dans
notre réforme, qui sont une
manière d'accompagner les
Français.
Ne sortez pas la vérité de cette
réforme.
Dites ce qu'elle contient plutôt
que d'essayer de la déformer en
faisant peur aux gens.
Cette réforme est nécessaire et
juste.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Vous avez cinq secondes.
- Aurélie Trouvé: Vous voyez,
monsieur le ministre?
Vous pensez avoir raison contre
tout le monde, mais tout le pays
est debout, et tout le pays sera
debout demain!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Guillaume Garot.
- Guillaume Garot: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre du Travail,
aujourd'hui, les Français se
mobilisent massivement à Paris, à
Marseille, à Toulouse, à
Maubeuge...
Ils se mobilisent massivement et
partout en France, pour dire non à
la réforme des retraites que vous
voulez imposer.
Massivement et encore plus
nombreux que le 19 janvier.
C'est une protestation de grande
ampleur.
Elle vient des profondeurs de
notre pays, parce qu'elle touche à
l'idée même que les Français se
font de la justice.
Ils ont bien compris, les
Français, qu'avec les 64 ans,
c'était les ouvriers, les
employés, les salariés qui ont
fait des études courtes qui
devront faire les plus grands
sacrifices, et que les femmes, en
particulier, allaient être
pénalisées, selon les mots d'un
ministre du gouvernement.
Alors, monsieur le ministre du
Travail, pour ne pas brutaliser
notre pays, pour ne pas le
fracturer davantage, pour ne pas
ajouter l'injustice aux
inégalités, quand allez-vous
retirer votre réforme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur, vous nous interrogez sur
le sens de la réforme.
Vous nous interrogez sur la
question de celles et ceux qui
commence à travailler tôt.
Les dispositifs que nous mettons
en place permettent de mieux
protéger celles et ceux qui
travaillent.
Dans le système que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui, système
qui se caractérise par deux
niveaux de prise en compte, ceux
qui ont travaillé avant 16 ans et
qui peuvent partir à 58 ans et
ceux qui peuvent partir avant 20
ans,
qui bénéficie de deux années de
départ anticipé.
Nous créons un troisième niveau
pour tenir compte de ceux qui
commencent à travailler entre 16
et 18 ans.
C'est cette mesure qui va
permettre que l'effort soit le
plus justement réparti.
Qu'est-ce qui, aujourd'hui, amène
les uns et les autres à travailler
plus tard?
Certes, le relèvement de l'âge,
mais aussi la réforme que nous
avons votée en 2013.
Vous étiez membre du gouvernement
lorsqu'a été voté le passage de 42
à 43 annuités, la durée minimum
pour avoir droit à une retraite à
taux plein.
Je suis parfois perplexe.
J'entends votre question et je me
demande si vous défendez la
proposition de votre Premier
secrétaire, une machine adéquate,
ou la proposition de votre nouveau
secrétaire délégué, qui considère
que c'est illusoire.
- Guillaume Garot: Le débat sera
utile s'il est de bonne foi et si
vous ne recourez pas à la
malhonnêteté intellectuelle.
Vous avez essayé de nous faire
croire que cette réforme était
juste.
Personne ne vous a cru.
Vous avez essayé de nous faire
croire que le régime était au bord
de la faillite, personne ne vous a
cru.
Vous nous dites aujourd'hui que
les Français doivent faire un
effort et que vous voulez imposer
les 64 ans, nous ne vous suivrons
pas davantage.
Sortez de votre obstination.
Sortez de votre entêtement et
écoutez les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Fanta Berete.
- Fanta Berete: Madame la
présidente, mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre du Travail et du Plein
Emploi.
Monsieur le ministre, tandis que
s'ouvre cette semaine l'examen sur
le projet de loi retraite, nous
devons à la population d'avancer
dans un contexte serein.
Que l'on soit pour ou contre cette
réforme, très bien.
Que l'on soit là pour assurer nos
convictions, en particulier si
elles divergent, très bien, c'est
le but, mais il se produit ici
quelque chose de très vicieux.
Tous les moyens sont-ils bons pour
porter nos convictions?
Ce que dit le texte est écarté au
profit de ce que l'on veut lui
faire dire, parce que l'objectif,
c'est de mettre les Français dans
la rue.
Du coup, s'agit-il vraiment de
lutter pour l'intérêt collectif?
On peut se le demander car, après
l'étape qui consistait à alimenter
les plateaux TV de propos
démagogues, de contrevérités et de
mensonges, oui, de mensonges,
quand on soutient par exemple
qu'une aide-soignante atteinte de
polyarthrite partira à 64 ans,
alors que le texte réaffirme que
les travailleurs handicapés
prendront leur retraite à partir
de 55 ans, c'est un mensonge.
Désormais, on passe à l'étape 2 de
la communication et des
agissements tendancieux avec les
fermetures des mairies par
solidarité.
Sous-entendant que même les
instances de la République
s'opposent à cette réforme.
C'est le summum de
l'instrumentalisation.
La maire de Paris évoque une
mesure symbolique, symbolique,
oui, du piège dans lequel certains
sont tombés, sous couvert de
l'intérêt du peuple de vouloir
gagner par tous les moyens en
popularité.
Le droit de grève est un droit
individuel.
Monsieur le ministre du Travail,
que pensez-vous d'un employeur
qui, et a fortiori d'un employeur
public, qui décrète de fermer sa
structure par solidarité avec une
manifestation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente...
Madame la députée, lorsque nous
sommes dans un moment de
mobilisation sociale, en ce qui
concerne les agents publics et les
employés, il y a deux principes à
respecter: d'abord, le droit de
grève.
C'est un droit constitutionnel que
nous respectons.
Chacun peut faire grève lorsqu'il
le juge utile.
Il y a un deuxième principe, celui
de la neutralité du service
public.
Vous me posez la question du
droit, et notamment l'appréciation
que nous pourrions porter sur les
déclarations, les décisions de la
maire de Paris.
Je pourrais évoquer la décision du
Conseil d'Etat de 2005 qui a
rappelé que les bâtiments publics
et les maires devaient rester
neutres et ne pouvaient pas
afficher de signes symboliques
politiques ou philosophiques sur
les façades des équipements
municipaux et des équipements
publics.
Je pourrais évoquer la cour
d'appel administrative de Lyon qui
a condamné la fermeture d'une
mairie en solidarité avec un
mouvement social.
Je pourrais évoquer les articles
711 et suivants du code de la
fonction publique qui rappelle le
principe du service fait qui
écarte la possibilité de payer les
agents grévistes.
Le paiement de la grève n'est pas
toléré.
Au-delà de ces questions de droit
qu'un jour un juge appréciera
peut-être, il y a une question
morale et une question politique.
J'ai été maire pendant neuf ans.
J'ai eu maintes occasions d'être
en conflit, en opposition avec les
différents gouvernements qui se
sont succédés, mais jamais je n'ai
pris les usagers en otage, jamais
je ne me suis servi des services
pour instrumentaliser un procès
politique, et encore moins un
procès en illégitimité.
Jamais je n'ai fait peser sur les
agents de la collectivité quelque
question et quelque pression que
ce soit.
C'est un principe de neutralité et
un principe de respect.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Pierre
Meurin.
- Pierre Meurin: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique.
Demain, le prix des péages va
augmenter de 4,75%.
Vous invoquez l'inflation pour
vous dédouaner, mais les Français
doivent savoir qu'en l'occurrence,
c'est faux.
Nous apprenons l'existence d'un
rapport de l'Inspection générale
des finances déposé sur votre
bureau en 2021.
Ce rapport est opportunément resté
dans un placard à quelques mois de
la présidentielle.
Nous apprenons que, depuis 2006,
la rentabilité des grandes
sociétés d'autoroute serait passée
de 7 à 12%.
L'IGF indiquerait qu'avec la même
qualité de service public, le prix
des péages pourrait être baissé de
60%.
Si nos autoroutes étaient toujours
exploitées par l'Etat, les caisses
pourraient récolter 50 milliards
d'euros.
Vous cherchez de l'argent pour
équilibrer le système des
retraites.
Au lieu de faire de la casse
sociale, allez chercher cet argent
dans la poche des actionnaires des
sociétés autoroutières.
Je vous ai envoyé la semaine
dernière un courrier.
Vous devez communiquer à la
représentation nationale ce
rapport.
Que cachez-vous?
Vous l'avez refusé tout à l'heure.
Vous osez vous féliciter d'une
baisse de 5% pour les plus riches
qui achètent une voiture
électrique.
Il est inacceptable que les
Français qui bossent trinquent sur
l'autel de la rentabilité des
grandes entreprises autoroutières.
Depuis des années, Marine Le Pen
demande la nationalisation des
autoroutes car il s'agit du bien
commun des Français.
De façon plus générale, votre
gouvernement a passé les six
dernières années à matraquer les
automobilistes avec une constance
qui frise le sadisme.
Vous refusez de baisser les taxes
sur le carburant, vous les avez
même augmentées.
Vous instaurez des ZFE pour
empêcher les plus modestes
d'accéder aux centres-villes.
Vous avez misé sur une politique
de sécurité routière du tout
répressif.
Quand allez-vous arrêter de
matraquer les automobilistes et
enfin défendre le pouvoir d'achat
des Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député, il
y a deux parties dans votre
question.
Une spécifique qui rejoint de
manière totale la question de La
France Insoumise et qui nous
rappelle que les propositions de
Marine Le Pen sont les mêmes que
celles de Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Dépenser 40 milliards pour acheter
les sociétés d'autoroutes et se
retrouver dans une situation où on
utiliserait l'argent des Français
pour aller le mettre dans le
rachat des autoroutes plutôt que
pour l'utiliser d'une autre
manière.
Vous m'expliquez que nous
invoquons l'inflation.
Le sujet n'est pas celui-là.
Il y a des contrats qui ont été
passés au milieu des années 2000.
Ni vous ni moi n'étions là.
Dans ces contrats, il y a des
clauses.
L'inflation et l'indexation du
prix est une des clauses.
Nous ne pouvons augmenter les
taxes que dans le cadre juridique
applicable.
C'est exactement ce que nous
faisons.
Deux contentieux qui sont en
cours, notamment à l'issue de la
disposition qui a été votée dans
la loi de finances 2020.
Je vous redonnerai mon adresse.
Je n'ai pas reçu de courrier de
votre part.
Pour une raison simple, en 2021 ou
en 2020, je n'étais pas dans cette
situation.
Maintenant, plus largement, vous
dites que le sujet, c'est le
matraquage systématique des
automobilistes.
Je sais que vous êtes un partisan
du retour inconditionnel aux 90
km/h, des 24 points au lieu des
12, et du fait de considérer qu'il
faut, vis-à-vis des
automobilistes, passer à une
espèce de vision qui consisterait
à les encourager.
Mais celui qui porte une vision
idéologique, c'est vous.
La constance que nous avons, c'est
la protection des Français.
Ca vaut pour la protection contre
la surmortalité liée à la
pollution de nos villes, et ça
vaut aussi avec la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique.
Votre scepticisme explique sans
doute le radicalisme de
l'opposition.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Quelques secondes.
- Pierre Meurin: Vous ne m'avez
pas répondu.
On va avoir la communication de ce
rapport?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Pierre
Dharréville.
- Pierre Dharréville: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
monsieur le ministre, rude journée
pour vous.
Si on regarde la situation avec un
peu de recul, vous êtes en
fâcheuse posture.
Vous avez essayé d'imposer une
réforme qui n'a pas de majorité.
L'ensemble des organisations
syndicales a appelé à manifester.
Le pays est dans la rue, encore
plus fort aujourd'hui.
Il faut mesurer, je crois,
l'ampleur de la colère.
Même dans votre majorité, sur les
bancs de la droite, le doute s'est
installé.
Vous avez déployé pourtant une
énergie considérable à essayer de
convaincre, à discréditer, à
décourager.
Maintenant, monsieur le ministre,
il faut écrire le scénario du
retrait, de l'abandon de cette
réforme qui est manifestement
illégitime.
C'est le plus sage.
C'est ce qui vous honorerait le
plus.
Tout le monde louerait votre
esprit de lucidité, de
responsabilité.
Personne ne croit, quand vous
parlez de justice, de solidarité
sociale.
Tout le monde a bien compris la
destruction que représente cette
réforme.
Tout le monde a bien compris que
votre projet, c'est d'allonger le
temps de travail d'un maximum de
gens et de faire baisser les
pensions des autres.
Il faut le prendre avec
philosophie.
Vous avez essayé, vous n'avez pas
réussi.
La République va mieux quand le
gouvernement est en phase avec la
volonté populaire.
Elle en sort grandie quand, après
un conflit, on trouve
l'apaisement.
Ce sera un moment désagréable à
passer, mais il faut s'y préparer,
le plus tôt sera le mieux.
Vous serez soulagé, ensuite, et le
monde du travail aussi.
La seule issue raisonnable, c'est
de renoncer.
Je comprends que vous n'allez pas
pouvoir me le dire maintenant,
tout de suite, d'autant que je
m'adresse à la Première ministre
et qu'elle est partie, mais
dites-nous à quelle heure vous
avez rendez-vous pour réévaluer la
situation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Merci pour vos propos et merci
pour la brillance avec laquelle
vous exprimez votre crainte que
cela pourrait être un moment
désagréable à passer.
Je n'ai aucun doute sur votre
bienveillance en la matière.
Je ne suis pas convaincu que ce
soit votre priorité première dans
notre semaine, mais ceci étant
dit, vous me dites qu'il faut
écrire le scénario du retrait,
mais nous le connaissons.
Si nous retirions cette réforme,
le système serait déficitaire, il
s'écroulerait.
Les pensions des retraités
baisseraient de 20%, comme c'est
indiqué.
Je ne suis pas sûr que vous
souhaitiez la fin du système par
répartition.
Je suis encore moins convaincu que
vous souhaitiez devoir baisser le
niveau de vie des retraités dans
votre pays.
Nous portons cette réforme pour
équilibrer le système, pour faire
en sorte qu'elle soit pérennisée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Vous n'avez plus de temps,
monsieur Dharréville.
Vous en aurez la semaine
prochaine, ne vous inquiétez pas.
La parole est à madame Estelle
Youssouffa.
- Estelle Youssouffa: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
Olivier Dussopt.
Je veux prendre ici le relais de
mon collègue de Mayotte et
expliciter la réalité des
retraites à Mayotte.
Il y a 2615 retraités à Mayotte.
Vous les avez oubliés.
Vous nous invitez à y réfléchir
ensemble, soit, dont acte.
Rappelons que le plafond de calcul
de la Sécurité sociale, qui sert
de base, est fixé par le
gouvernement à 65,3% du montant
national.
C'est votre entière
responsabilité.
Paris nivelle Mayotte par le bas.
La retraite moyenne est de 276
euros à Mayotte, 276 euros par
mois, en-deçà du seuil national de
pauvreté.
A Mayotte, nos anciens sont
condamnés à l'indignité.
Le système leur promet
l'indigence.
A Mayotte, la retraite la plus
faible s'élève à 9 euros par mois.
Sachez que c'est le prix du pack
d'eau, à Mayotte, puisque nous
avons pas d'eau potable.
Il est impossible de parler de
retraite sans parler du coût de la
vie.
Le coût du panier alimentaire est
60% plus cher à Mayotte.
L'inflation dépasse celle de
l'Hexagone et atteint 7,1% sur
notre île.
Au 1er janvier, le SMIC national
est passé à 1700,09 euros.
A Mayotte, il a été augmenté à
1290 euros.
Nous travaillons tout autant, je
rassure tout le monde, mais nous
sommes payés 418 euros de moins.
Encore une discrimination par
décret.
Une pauvreté systémique pour nous.
Vous parlez de justice pour cette
réforme, qui ne propose rien pour
Mayotte, rien pour les
ultramarins, rien pour les
fonctionnaires ultramarins qui
voient s'éteindre l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite.
Ils demandent simplement à cotiser
davantage pour espérer une
retraite digne.
Quelle justice pour les
travailleurs et les retraités de
Mayotte?
Quelles mesures proposez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Un mot pour dire que nous n'avons
pas oublié les retraités de
Mayotte.
Je l'ai dit tout à l'heure.
Nous savons très bien la situation
particulière du régime de retraite
à Mayotte.
Il a été créé en 1987.
Il n'y a pas de régime
complémentaire obligatoire.
Il n'y a que 2500 pensionnés
aujourd'hui.
Lorsque nous regardons quelle est
la carrière, pour les retraités
concernés, il apparaît que
seulement 9 aient réellement
cotisé.
Tout cela est le fruit d'une
histoire plus longue d'un point de
vue administratif.
Il y a des périodes de convergence
que nous observons aujourd'hui.
Convergence sur l'assiette de
cotisations.
Convergence sur le nombre de
trimestres exigibles pour le droit
à la retraite au taux plein.
Le résultat...
Pardon, madame.
Je suis désolé, je vais jusqu'au
bout de ma réponse.
Vous l'avez dit vous-même, la
retraite moyenne à Mayotte est de
287 euros.
Est-ce que c'est acceptable?
Non.
Est-ce que c'est facile à
résoudre?
Non plus.
Les paramètres de ce projet ne
correspondent pas à la réalité
inconnue par les assurés et par
les pensionnés à Mayotte.
Mettons à profit cette période, ce
texte, et le travail que nous
avons à faire pour accélérer la
convergence.
Cela passe par la revalorisation
des pensions, par l'accélération
de tous les paramètres de la
convergence.
Je ne sous-estime pas le travail.
Je sais combien c'est une
impatience que vous exprimez
aujourd'hui.
Mettons-nous tout simplement au
travail.
Le projet tel que nous le portons
ne serait pas bon s'il était
appliqué à Mayotte, mais profitons
de ce débat pour apporter les
réponses.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La séance des questions au
gouvernement est terminée.